over here in chin wearing now let's just
get into it man yeah Brian's late ft-1
sends me it takes it goes bro lost track
of time be there soon
who loses track of time I don't even
know what that is by the way I don't
even know what losing track of time is
but here's the problem we've been doing
the show for six years
yeah it's the same time every Wednesday
yeah if it but it's so you know it's not
like oh it's a crazy Thursday and yeah
except I suppose when I have a guest it
was just me I'm used to it
yeah I do did I used to have inner
demons
mmm thing about killing Brian would he'd
be late so I probably quit the show four
to five times because he's late all the
time yeah and they stop being late he
hasn't been late in a while
yeah it used to be a real problem yeah
I'm just like a chalk it up it's Brian
yeah but you can kind of see that with
Brian's progression in life he lost
track it's always been losing trackers
yeah and now it's really hitting them
and now it's like hey I'm gonna do a
special it's like I think you lost track
of time
yeah that should have been done 15 years
ago but yeah hey good job well promote
promote it dude we're before we started
going live we're talking about fashion
because you're always a fashionable dude
you got my favorite off whites on right
now yeah the Presto this is this is the
best this I don't even consider this a
collab I don't even consider this Nike I
consider this a piece like this is a
piece of artwork from Virgil agree and
and like you know you can put this on
display and everyone's gonna be like you
know what is that like that's how I look
at this shoe if this is be best this is
the best design since the Jordan 4 or
the Jordan 3 I'm a fan of the ones to
the ones I yeah I get it but the ones
were just a sleeker version like an Air
Force or whatever it's still a dope shoe
dunk yeah yeah it's just it's just a
sleeker version of that but the three
was kind of like what saved my chol from
leaving to go to adidas I think he was
gonna go to adidas or converse and that
was a shoe that saved it the three so
three I'm the man I think that because
I grew up during that era I remember
when the three came out and I remember
all of us come on a footlocker just to
look at it on the wall there was such a
big deal it was crazy because we
couldn't believe what we were seeing
there was like there's no swoosh we were
like what but it's crazy it's on a high
top the others now there's really
nothing like that is nothing there's
nothing that the Yeezys I guess create
the kind of pandemonium that comes with
it does it though not the same ammonium
does it pandemonium okay cause like I
see people wearing the easies and I'm
like okay are you wearing them cuz you
really truly truly love the desert you
know or is it because this is the hot
thing and everyone's talking about like
when the Jordan hit the Jordan [ __ ]
hit hit hit Jordan like trying to shoe
game I feel I feel like changes a
sketball agree forever forever I feel
like with Yeezys and even I do own a
bunch of them didn't pay from but people
send to me and when I put them on I
think the same thing I'm like am I
wearing this has actually dig them they
are comfy super comfy like do they look
at Rock you're comfy you're right eggs
are comfy bugs are Tom Brady can't wear
ugh yeah no no I'm just saying though
like like I see people rocking my house
or no no I don't not one pair I just
they never check so this drive this shoe
right here there's another pair of all
flights that that hit me right in the
ass
the 97th the Air Max that he did oh yeah
and I was just like have you IVs water
shoe have you seen his the first
off-white Air Force once the clears yep
my son got those my son I literally
bought the whole wall when they came out
that whole round that came it was so
funny I got a text from Chris Chris
D'Elia and he he was like I'd say the
three but hate dinner I'd say you me and
Chris in comedy probably the top
sneakerheads oh hey sound good clothes
yeah I can and I'm a cheap ride by the
way I'm mochi I talked you about it for
me I talked about you on oh my god the
show I just did I'll look it up and say
it but they were like you know his game
is hard right and I was like yeah he's
killing it right now like his shoe game
is hot and then I looked at the camera
girl but I'm og yeah you use original it
goes you Chris
yeah Chris it was so funny because Chris
you know when he's open for me I didn't
know that yeah yeah I took Chris on the
road and um because you saw him at the
economy store I saw him at the hahaha
and you're like that kids talented
I saw Vince he must have been doing it a
year and a half
Wow and I saw him and I was like what he
got off stage Jason Collins introduced
me to him and then I went in Psalm at
the ha ha
and and I just walked up to him we were
already friends and I go hey you want to
go on the road with me and for a year
and about it a little over a year he
went on the road with me Wow
yeah we were crushing her I was you know
I was already getting like you know I
was already selling out weekend I'm in
here he goes this it's probably 11 years
ago yeah yeah so Chris is so cool man
yeah for a year yo he'd go it was so
funny Chris was gonna be like at I knew
is he gonna be the back I kept on Jamie
methought I was like what are you doing
like this guy needs bein in the laughs
actor what are you doing nah buddy he's
not ready I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about disguiser
come on like I took him on the road and
I love putting people in front of me
that are [ __ ] strong but what I don't
like following people that are like me
how inside I fight I find it funny when
comics do that yeah with a sandbag where
they'll put a bro like bro you see it
too don't you see I'm like because as I
hate it I was a fan of cambia fire I do
it so you want the you want the audience
have the best show possible always if
you put [ __ ] in front of you
yo it doesn't really make you look
better no like god those guys were awful
awful the crowds kind of off it's not
yeah you see you know what I'm talking
about
I don't want to see any news there's a
lot of guys that do that I take it that
personally sandbag the show bro I take a
guy named Eric post and he's a dork at
the Comi store uh I want to say who but
big-name comics that we know we're
bringing him he crushes yeah they don't
bring them anymore
I don't get it yeah I I have to have
someone that crushes in front of me I
love that feeling of like oh [ __ ] I hope
I can follow him or oh god I gotta bring
it up tonight I got a I got a step you
know I mean I got you so good though I
don't want to like
I just told you know where I got it from
Cedric the Entertainer I opened for
Cedric and it was in a kinda I don't
know how many years ago this is like 14
years ago and I was opening for him at
some Indian Reservation and I crushed
I'm not gonna like me I was like 3,500
people there I'm [ __ ] blind audience a
lot audience bro people are standing you
know I said good night they stood up
there screaming I walk off to the side
of stage I see Cedric on the side the
stage got a spa door on he's got his
suit on he's bouncing like a fighter
like in the corner of the Ring and he's
like that's what I'm saying [ __ ]
make me work for this money money yeah
make me work for this [ __ ] that's what
I'm talking about joke boy and he
slapped my hand and walked out and they
literally forgot who the [ __ ] I was and
I was like that I need to be him that's
who I need to be most of the big dogs
are like that don't a man most of them
ya ain't worried about I don't get it
dude when I was coming up man out of
that Laugh Factory spot when I mean
there there are cats that were like you
know they were the strong cats that you
want to fall in then there was those
guys that loved it when you were in
front of him but then there's a few of
them that were like oh he's on let me
bump him or I'll see you guys now where
you'll they'll be like up now let me go
here let me go here just just cuz well
it doesn't mean that he's stealing
laughs they're all out of laughs bro is
that what is it if it's leather yeah you
don't run out of laughs laughs company's
gross yeah funny so you're funny you're
funny
Wow it your eyes I was talking yesterday
with Derek and a son there Tommy store
door guys dude you're never at the store
really I didn't really went through the
the store but you know you know I was
blessed with Jamie Masada like Jamie
when he first Ralphie may is the one
that told Jamie to sign me and the guy
yeah because there was no other rooms
that I could get spots up at you know
what I mean so when you first start when
I first came here but I was already 13
years in because I started in Vegas so I
was doing like rooms that I was like
booking theaters myself like I was
booked in I had this one theater Pro I
go way back when I'm sorry but like I
would get sponsors to pay for my theater
rooms and one of my sponsors was Dada
footwear I don't remember that ever do
and and and Biggie Smalls use and LL
Cool J's to wear the hats cool man yeah
and and and I got them to sponsor my
shows I ended up meeting the owner and
the owner started sponsoring my shows
I'm still best friends with the guy that
did the marketing Carlos Perot and and
he was they were they were paying for my
shows out there and I got JB's moved to
come out I got honest John Jay Lamont
Michael Blackson I was doing this in
like 95 monsters yeah man and and and
that's I was comfortable so I lived in
Vegas because I was making money off
these shows nobody came to LA you're
like I was already 13 years in but I but
when I came to LA I was like okay I did
13 years of stand-up and Here I am
coming to LA and now it's like ground
zero again you don't change yeah so
imagine like being able to like so we
even all these guys but so were you kind
of like like it the story like now I
don't need to get past I'm known for 13
years
exactly I mean that was my atomy work
yeah I didn't understand that there was
just I can see process to get in
hierarchy yeah and then and then there
was like this theme show at a laugh
actory and I got in on that theme show
it's called Asian invasion and I know
all Asians yeah well now really it PK uh
Amy Anderson used to look who's late
look who's lost track of time yeah
you're 50 though yeah how's that happen
I am okay I know I can trust you guys
not to make fun man you're ready for the
worst lie you've heard what I've been
doing for quite some time I could
understand get ready spread around can I
say this to you guys without you guys
making funny 100% there's not my son
starts zero like they're so bad at the
same they're so bad it makes my day huh
Bay yeah yeah yeah I had to walk my dog
I had to make breakfast that's not an
excuse the other thing I understand yeah
I'll take a shot that's not ice cream
you don't have the gun in your apartment
this is a vulnerable for me I have a
case of the squirts
there you go all right yeah you're so
much more creative yeah yeah yeah yeah
but there's so much more creative yeah
at least come up with something yeah and
my husband
oh just bad dude yeah that's a that's a
lie
you don't excuse me well you're a liar
this this strain just keeps on going
done it yeah it's the fighter in the koi
now what role you're out this thing no
no you remember that that whole thing
where you lose track of time
yeah this is what happens during that
time listen you lose track of time
yeah that little that area that you miss
yeah it gets build in people forget
about people forget check now it's a
common now it's Brendan Connor those two
comments Oh
7,000 negative ones negative now it's
Brendan chicoy yeah oh boy it's your koi
boys in the house everyone chicoy oh you
would love but this I really don't like
you I don't even know why I don't even
know why come on dude I don't have the
anger anymore but when Brian used to be
late if he's younger I swear to God my
just saying this I would I'd want to
fight you oh you would yeah not anymore
though I'm good not older rich whatever
used to does it matter used to want to
fight does it matter anyway that'd be
I'd be like that twenty five minutes
then I was will sasso late yeah I used
to be real satellite in this room this
was all I had at the time yeah like I'm
gonna I'm gonna fisticuff yeah oh I want
to hurt him but you're too old yeah it
would ruin my reputation yeah
but if I were younger if you were you
might have given me a shot of what you
are you were to give me a shove about no
wait a minute love hold on yeah if he
was 30 Hey 31 is Shaun
jardim audience your course seriously
you know I joke oi well no no you know I
don't have time to call your whole name
to my safety has the hottest special on
Netflix and you met you can't you show
up late dude your special looks very fun
oh why cuz Hollywood be lower to ranked
him top-five comics in the you're doing
well in the world do you know why
because I didn't sell out Brea and then
somebody goes dude bye
jo koy saw that like 70 times when and
that doesn't help her jaws hurt I'm not
him yeah her jaw hurts your feelings no
it doesn't hurt my feelings
he's the best yeah like this don't go
lighter in the koi not in the koi no I
don't know what color paint we're gonna
use for my face on that wall but no come
on what we're actually moving Studios
Monday dude what do you were aa young
close he looks awesome I think right I
know how to put it together or not young
I'm not I'm not doing the whole laundry
day looked that you like to do this is
that cash like hey I gotta do my laundry
tonight there's so warcasters what I
have I got it Vince that's not that I
came here yes see that's not cash feel
it what is cashmere what is it you wanna
know yeah what is it it's a sheep it's a
type of sheep that comes from the
Kashmir Valley oh yeah depends where
whoa what happened bro what happened
that's not what it is yes it is that's
not what he just silk really come from
worms yes I'm [ __ ] know it
yeah so comes from or let those worms to
work dude is super strong is it really
yeah really strong and Gucci makes the
best I'm crazy you don't got some crazy
no idea what I'm saying like like they
can
I think it's stronger in some ways than
steel I don't know if that's well glad
you're here yeah we lad you're here we
were getting deep getting real deep
comedy do you know daliyah opened up for
him he brought him on the road Virginie
i opened up for me well for him you went
you went boom Delia yeah little [ __ ]
y-yeah or do you find that now that
you're playing these massive arenas hmm
do you miss the intimacy of a club at
all or no I do yeah
yeah I mean I still play the club's you
do yeah yeah but I I do miss you still
give to the poor people
no stop just kill I do i do I too enjoy
uh the smaller rooms I like to interact
and you know cuz when you do the big
rooms you gotta play you gotta play big
you don't you got them jokes back you're
like could you shut your special in
Hawaii yeah you know job like basically
on the island of Oahu yeah this is just
on the island bro yeah I play reality
while we put a stage everybody watch in
middle of the fall yeah just the island
where'd you play what's funny about your
story is that I think Netflix kept
passing yeah I had no idea how funny you
were or yeah they did but they just for
whatever reason it just kept passing and
then ate me off yeah didn't understand
what was going no it was crazy because I
was like I'm selling out 17 Brea shows
in a row and I'm like I'm even offering
to fly them to a gig I was like hey I
got I got these shows I'll fly you and
fly you back the same night just like
just watch this set please give me an I
need this hour special and and literally
they were just like here we're gonna
pass we got all the specials for the
rest of the year so we'll come see you
next year for 2018 2015 so straight how
happy are they now
why shot it myself and I know you did
and I'm not just saying this because
you're here I can't tell you how many
people have hit me up my dude jo koy
special everyone pressed last week the
week before everyone dude have you seen
jo koy specially that's my guy man I was
talking to someone I forget but they go
dude I've seen jo koy special and I go
that's my guy they go no [ __ ] way I'm
like yeah I'm texting with him right now
this is my guy man but what's funny
about that is that I've known you of 20
years maybe yeah you've never not been
you never not crushed I've never seen
you not crush and what's funny is it
just takes the business that long to
catch up it's like I remember watching
you a [ __ ] do well first of all you
should kill on Chelsea but I remember
the Laugh Factory this is what I was
turning over in like this these are the
guys that I was talking about like when
he would walk in these are the guys that
we were like the guys that were just
coming into the laughs act it like when
you would walk in we would all be like
house [ __ ] he's about to go up you gotta
follow him you know I mean like but I
loved it I loved watching you go he
would do the [ __ ] you're vulture and
[ __ ] you would have all this ego all I
did the Eagle off [ __ ] I would love it
and but that that's what made I love
that challenge of being able to follow
you we're saying how guys have set
before you got here yeah we're saying
out guys sandbag like the foot [ __ ]
in front of them so they look bad no we
were all it was it when you had to
follow Joe no
I'm saying uh I'm saying on the road
brother right you know but speaking
comics to bring guys that aren't that
good on so they look better I never did
that I don't understand that I brought I
brought the best guy I could find yeah
because I think it makes the show better
and yes you know but my thing is with
you with Netflix I don't I feel like you
don't need that like but I know you want
to be on there but I don't see why you
need that cosign like for me it's
different right like I need I needed a
Showtime because I come from a different
background and to be legitimate I need
someone to co-sign that knows comedy
right so I have to have that I can't
just upload it to YouTube because any
slap dick here you can do that but
you're so ingrained you're killing it
everywhere like maybe your neck
specially this my thing though it's like
would like when when they told me they
passed I was like well [ __ ] Netflix like
alright who cares but then now what does
I feel like you're better than I and it
I'm just saying like you don't need them
there's certain guys that don't need
them well they're like I hear Netflix
I'm like alright but to be you're gonna
get so many of them at one thing I would
say is it a lot of America has it and
it's very convenient and even on my TV
there's a Netflix button mm-hmm for
channel playing so syllabus it brings up
and then jo koy is there you are gonna
get more eyeballs for now I do think
it's changing for now I wanted Netflix
mainly because the first two specials I
had they shelved on Comedy Central
so so you did a for Comedy Central yeah
they know what you're worth and then I
passed on that what year was that on
Comedy Central oh man I don't know ten
years ago so and that's where they
erased you better watch it Friday at 7
p.m.
otherwise you're not gonna [ __ ] no one
saw it and no and I love those first two
specials but that's not kind of cynical
is it they're great did you see you I
didn't see them but I know they're real
that you were doing no I know that they
must have been destroyed and no one sees
but you know ills me but that's not
coming Central's fault right like that's
that was the business though that's
Comedy Central that many years ago like
what were they gonna do I mean they
didn't really have a promotion do you
know there's no content you know I think
you should do because it's what I'm
gonna do for my Latin last two specials
don't give it ideas
no I'm gonna no no I'm gonna um redo
like man class right mmm those bits used
to [ __ ] destroy the stuff you talk
about I'm gonna redo I'm gonna once in a
while I'm just gonna do an old feel with
that you're that's a good idea to hold
their old start to an old bit and I'm
gonna put it up on YouTube and I'm just
gonna do that with every one of my
[ __ ] bits today I do that with your
bug yes there's some bits man that is
right gone oh no we got to see they're
not on digit they're like great songs
that nobody ever heard yeah man right
yeah man I'm gonna do that I'm in 100% I
love that idea I'm taking those bits and
I'm gonna literally put them up I love
that yeah I love that idea I don't want
him to go away
you know you sorry no go ahead you could
just do like a night at the comic store
in the main room fulfillment of your
best bit for an hour of your classic bit
I'm gonna just chop it up let's really
sit down I love that idea it's a good
idea I really love that idea not because
people yell it out all the time people
yell out ting ting to me all the time
and I can't do it like I can't even get
myself to do an ice age but it's like no
one got to see that bit no I got to see
it they say it's only gonna hide behind
he said and you own it well the [ __ ]
that you were doing see what they sell
more tickets no but I will say that
before Joe I know this for like I've saw
it like before you became jo koy in
terms of like where everybody knows you
the [ __ ] you were doing back then was
like a machine gun
oh good good good good I mean it would
just be like but I really liked it right
off the I almost said the boat sorry
[ __ ] I know I'm taking changer of alias
for his handicap myself and I remember
the first words I said was is this thing
on
strong Filipino actor okay yeah how's
everybody doing tonight
I remember that what's the first I
remember that memory I was a real racist
friend oh such a racist
[ __ ] immigrant yeah used to say that
you cannot get your [ __ ] immigrant
and I would go back and I shove you
around yeah you shove me around yeah and
and I still I would I would hammer
through man I may tell you that was my
closer is this thing I used to sell
shirt yeah is this thing I know one
thing I had all my teeth have been
ripped out of my mouth I was one of
those ah you I thought you had a dip in
no I got a dip and I was like that's
cool ah man
what happened I had two veneers see that
yeah so I I have veneers well all of our
veneers but I fell on a rock when I was
a kid and that's why I got the veneers
and then uh the the the stud that was in
here F collapsed two days ago and they
had to rip it out of my mouth and reach
yeah cuz I had a stud in there since I
was like like thirteen when I fell on
the rock and it's you know the material
they were using back then was like steel
or something not healthy and it
collapsed so all this has been ripped
out and they put new ones every days ago
they put new my teeth in two days I put
this nice yeah they put new ones in yeah
there's these are all temps I get my new
ones in two week that's it's gonna hurt
when they put that in yeah there's
anything worse than mouth pain oh
nothing
how about like tooth problems thank God
for modern day dental oh my god what did
we do I know what we did we lost our
teeth I was that when I was in Tempe
Arizona
this guy had that's exactly what
happened huh that's exactly what just
ripped it out it's not whose teeth are
the third ones in yeah who is that that
is [ __ ] rat yeah [ __ ] what is so
you know what that is that's when they
file the Tia
veneers yes do all your [ __ ] yeah
they filed all of mine like that yeah
it's all not but now I'm missing teeth
I'm not doing what veneers amount that
hurt you think this guy right here ever
says um what is it that you don't like
about me he ever you have abused my said
I don't get it I don't think it is he
could does he go like this beauty skin
deed yeah
I'm a nice guy I'm a good guy
well I met a guy in Tempe and he was a
masseuse
yeah and he was a kind of a handsome guy
and he was missing his front teeth yeah
both and yeah and I and he was very
self-conscious of it he obviously
doesn't the money for teeth and I went
to I swear to god I was gonna say to my
friend I was gonna be like listen I will
pay for his teeth I would be I'd be
willing to give him $4,000 did jaunty
you know what it doesn't matter I didn't
because I she left I don't have a number
and I [ __ ] regretted it this the same
the same sign up they were like that
they were like that the bottom right
down let me help this what do you help
this guy I will too late now yes I don't
like the people are walking around
without front you have to have fun did
you know he wasn't he was a big thick
guy but no front teeth is it yeah that's
tired it's tough but is it you you don't
even know the story though like you
might want to know this like I said is
he a big hockey guy he that's there look
he was African American and I don't
believe they're allowed on the ice okay
now sorry edit right there's nothing
wrong okay no times exist I heard I
heard they're not I don't know anything
now now a lot of times again this isn't
this in a black-white thing or age
nothing this is just whatever sometimes
in certain cultures when they're instant
teeth it could be a craft thing yes he
wasn't though he's very he was a robust
low back you lose teeth yeah but he was
really seated when he spoke he was a
robust I it he was a bust
looking man robust yeah yeah you love
that word he was robust he was muscular
yeah big strong uh so yeah do Craig nice
got out I don't think that's what it was
I think he got probably punched her fell
on a rock because he's a [ __ ] like
decoy wait sorry
yeah that's crazy wait he was massaging
you know he was a masseuse and so was my
friend ha take that out there and that's
that weird one down makes you feel sick
yeah it's a tough one got teeth man he
they're no joke right if your duty got
bad teeth chicks what for whatever
reason we'll still deal with it if
you're successful
if you're a chick with bad teeth you are
game set match yeah it's over it's done
it's over
yeah I'm pretty bad with that too man if
you have [ __ ] up feet - and you're a
woman oh you're a foot guy yeah it's
it's done dude it's done if you got the
big knuckle on the side the the bunion
all these are my bunions yeah the bunion
or even that the two coins the coin huh
why the Conchords do you know look like
horns do you know what a murder or
stomach you know the thumbs talk about
the the one that goes all the way back
no this is H over it's cut
yeah we round the shitty thumb would ya
what do you mean bring it up bring up I
think it's called murderers thumb I
don't hear you and I have hitchhiker
thumbs right do we do what do you have
look at see those see that huh you see
that thumb which one you enjoy I have
thumb right there yeah it's it's a half
thumb see right there
oh how it's wide and flat yeah looks
like it's pressed - oh we got a picture
of it though because it throws me off
tad it really does it's like whoo boy
looks like your big toe it looks like
I'll take big looks like it looks like a
bit right there you got a big toe I'm
done brother bad teeth right there was a
girl I thought was so hot she had that
man I went oh thank God because I was
like I didn't think she liked me and I
was I got I was right ah I'm fine yeah
yeah I'm good I I remember I was with
this girl cute right and I'm just like I
hope she likes me and at the end of the
night she goes you're so nice and put
her hand on my face and I'm just like
what the [ __ ] is that on your hand
come earth um the big toe thumb it was a
big it was just the biggest yeah Ian
yeah I lied in flat well that's like
dating I went on a date with this girl's
on the Canadian national water polo team
yeah and she was so hot but strong and
muscular I like a muscular girl like a
[ __ ] and she had a big [ __ ] but I when I
when I whe she laced her hands in mine
yeah and her hands were as big and thick
his money yeah her knuckles oh well
remember our friend at the Laugh Factory
he was like dude meet this
oh cool oh he goes to shake my hand roll
to golf smiling go she was a regular you
know what to say I'd sweat nice to me
that's true like to I like to I'm from
it dude yeah he looks at me he goes her
hands are seven times aside somehow no
this isn't gonna wear a small woman you
got big hands big palms so your hands in
law dude she [ __ ] his head Chitra
small though very pretty killin and she
had giant mitts [ __ ] mitts how do you
not notice that he goes oh my god you're
right I go go go put your hand next to
hers yeah yeah she and then you look
high fiber high fiber when you said that
to me ago did you see her hands they
didn't say how are you oh my hand on my
way Joe if you're a foot guy
cat gets hit up non-stop suppose picture
a few people pay her for pictures all
for the beat Asians usually have nice
feet though
yeah Asian women have nice feet they
usually have the the little toenail on
the small toe bright yellow fool toenail
have a small toenail yeah them I did you
too girl that painted the skin there and
I and I caught on to it later on I'm
like this is there's no nail there
[Laughter]
because yeah the Pilger nail just fell
off I mean my nails not great that's
your OSAP dude feet yeah you ready
uterus was that Dhupia shakes or nuts
was that dude I'm sorry
well I feel like only Asian males ever
do so Asians always have cute are you a
foot guy yeah I'm a foot guy nah man
100% yeah if you have a bad cards right
maybe cat appeal but I think sometimes
if you're from like if you're of Dutch
extraction and you're a big Germanic
woman sometimes it can be hot then you
look down they've got [ __ ] without
large understanding they have some big
feet like the big toes and those long
toes oh yeah yeah girl and you're like
wait a minute that's a giant big toe
yeah and you've got your your middle toe
is extending you talk about the et it
looks like et fresh it's longer you want
to write sir
it's antennae doing that up might be
have a long second toe yeah yeah
most peoples are longer though I feel
like I'm forget
I'm more forgiving really you're really
hot I can tell with your feet if you're
really hot i'm battle teeth if you're
really how you don't have to have feet I
don't know man I'll help
oh that's gotta go no matter that might
be a picture of my feet my that's how my
feet look yeah you got your dude I know
but still it's not good you know I'm
gonna conch my big toe it's so big is it
it shows they don't know I mean I guess
I would be like take my shoes is it
because of fighting oh that's what
happens okay it's cut off in traffic and
it's Phil peeing off the the other songs
crying take that off yeah yeah my big
toes so big man it's just wide you know
I have Flintstone feet do you have fat
Fiat fat fee mines fat and wide yeah
that's what she's saying people who wear
who've never worn I don't understand
that oh my dude girls I didn't do why
are sandals and your feet hang over the
top over the top out of my face go home
go get the socks digits we're somewhat
soft you can't wear sandals were they
[ __ ] it no hang like your shoes
aren't a ride for your foot yeah that's
hanging out are you a [ __ ] human
eagle and it's worth and it's worth what
do you grab the shoes yeah and it's work
as your feet have to really work this
you've been here know what you can hear
a dragging Brown I know wear sexy heels
and it's got the webbing you know the
leather webbing that goes across all the
feet and then the pinky toe comes out
bit of the way it comes out of the way
that's that it's the lonely bird out
yeah yeah just show it like it's just
looking out like that or I like through
our lonely not without bring up like
feet that have never worn shoes but but
but also but also I hate when girls like
whether it's [ __ ] Louis Vuitton's or
whatever and they're they love them and
their feet are [ __ ]
sandwiched in and they're red yeah red
cuz they can't [ __ ] breathe now
they're being chosen
those are feet that I've never worn
shoes those are how oh those are my feet
your feet my feet look look at that
that's my big toe Wow one of my son has
they guys ever wearing shoes with your
feet just have a chance to breathe and
they get wide yeah it had a light yeah I
think it you look like a [ __ ] man
duck oh look at that guy
telling you bro these are what my feet
look like that's gonna read me and you
didn't break your foot ever kick in I
broke my big toe kicking you did oh my
god not in fighting it over with we have
to break your big toe yep kind of over
oh geez all these just it's getting sad
now chin for god sake yeah I broke my
big toe not fight never both my toes
fighting I broke my toe
playing kickball in a middle school nice
yeah not a fan blew it up Oh what Jesus
yeah because I was in a sling at the
time and we're playing dodgeball and of
course I lasted the longest as miiverse
like three kids and so I was like I
can't well I just wasn't throwing us in
the back dodging and then the if the
whole [ __ ] class is watching we're
playing to a restroom on I forget this
and so on yells kick it because I don't
have shoes on like oh yeah I can't throw
so I'm gonna kick getting these kids out
so I line it up everyone's go Brandon
Brandon like this me so [ __ ] sick
let's do this
I go to kick and my I kick as hard as I
can my hit hit stuff oh my god instead
of the ball hits the ground goes oh and
my nail it just compound fracture that's
like a Oh John Jones the foot Oh after
his fight huh it's not like that guys I
had a compound fracture the worst of any
kind come on now femur fracture no you
did not yeah who has a tough one to do
why she showed us I don't have underwear
on what I'll show you motorcycle
motorcycle do you don't wear undies be
careful you're gonna have to take your
pants off holy [ __ ] you're gonna have to
take your pants on what happened and
what happened did it - I promised cats
on - NDA oh dude it's like a shark bite
that's that's like a straight-up shark
bites that how'd it happen dude
motorcycle I was called it okay
got hit by another motorcycle stamping
down a trail and I knew it - I knew it I
knew something bad was about to happen
I was hitting it come around like a turn
and then another bike just hit me
head-on like xxx dude that's cool yeah
man I think it broke on contact hold on
and when I'm cycling hit your leg I
think I think he broke my leg now and
then when I hit the ground that's when
it came out did you pass out of your
oh yes compound oh did you pass out from
the pain no I couldn't and then we go
Viney
and they pulled it they pulled it right
did what I was so I I had I had a broken
tibia fibula to see this is Albert do
that Jesus Christ motorcycle yeah don't
I don't know why people drive them I
don't get it you [ __ ] idiot there's
so many I'm gonna die well not even your
fault it's always the tostones also is
the drive my buddy my buddy is the
doctor of the catastrophic injury
Institute in West Virginia Hospital I
walk through those hallways everyone
who's paralyzed will never walk again
every single one that I saw or brain
dead motorcycle ATV ATVs ago worse
because they fall on you they bouncing
oh yeah and you flip over top of you
[ __ ] one after another I was like oh
make those illegal or make a cage around
them don't have ATVs without a cane like
it's so crazy without a roll bar you're
like and these kids don't know they go
too fast like we always do boat bump the
thing goes chute and they've been a
cross whistle and that's the end it's so
that was your last day on motorcycle
yeah yeah that was the last time [ __ ]
that's a cap in a triangle pin through
this this bone and pulled it with
weights and I literally degrow the
bathroom I had to pull it myself
take it off how old were you at this
time 14 it turned 15 in the hospital oh
you sure young I guess that's why when
I'm on the freeway I always pulled to
this side when I see a bike I always
pull over and make way for him yeah
cuz I don't want to be I I don't I don't
want to see them crash even if it's not
my fault oh so I can just get out of the
way and not see it because they're
driving like [ __ ] anyway yeah
they're flying down the two lanes
splitting cars no dangerous I don't know
why they do it and and I'm and here's
the thing I am Telling I'm telling your
viewers right now
if you're on a motorcycle I'd lane
change without a blinker I just want you
to know that most people do I'm the word
means [ __ ] lane changer so if you're
gonna come this is a racial thing
I'm not look but if you're gonna come
down it's 65 70 miles per hour during
rush hour yeah down two lanes cars I
change without my arrows are they gonna
hit me one day yeah and here's the thing
I'm most sometimes I'm in my giant truck
I won't even you won't even feel it bro
I just keep going yeah and I do feel it
and it turns me sorry no but motorcycles
solar cycles aren't just like but so
when it's dead stop traffic and they're
going down the center I'm talking about
me sometimes like god I wish I was like
I'm talking to a guy I'm talking to a
guy tell me who's guys gonna be an
Ontario in 15 I guess gonna beat me to
the valley and yeah thirty minutes pal
I'm talking this guy and his buddy they
were they were riding motorcycles and a
dude drove by them at night it was late
at night shot him with a 22 what shot
him right through the [ __ ] if the
bullet went made a clean
I guess went through his like back but
hit him in a non vital area right
through he's driving and he goes like
this he goes oh I've been shot the guy
just came out POW like that Jane gang
activity it was just a random thing
there on a highway and like not buying
it just driving red duncan yeah gang
some psycho some psycho was like I had
another guy tell me that sometimes you
never know when somebody's gonna try to
run you off the road there are psychos
who just go nobody's watching well when
they get off on it I I just can't
imagine riding a motorcycle oh it's
stupid what I do what's [ __ ] stupid
is I take the pain in Canyon or Laurel
Canyon yeah I'm here every day there's
guys on I'm not not motorcycles bike box
oh and I'm like these ones how he was
really like this and you're morons move
out lane they're backed up traffic like
crazy dude what the [ __ ]
I see yeah yeah that makes me so mad
what are you doing go on another trail
is it also in the front yeah are you
getting paid to wear that why are you
dressed like why are you dressed like
Lance Armstrong right right are you
competitive why is there a team of you
yeah
why is there a team why is there ten of
you why are you guys drafting yeah I'd
already drafting for speed
you're still the slowest [ __ ] people
on the run same surely you're not share
the rope get are you hey get out of here
she have a more motor suck it yep yep
[ __ ] every day I deal with them man
yeah that's [ __ ] if you're on our
roads if people that drive cars pay for
those roads that's our row it's tax
yours if you're if you're riding a bike
you are you're borrowing our road here's
the other thing that you don't have the
right to that road walkers here's the
other thing so they want to be like oh
we're part of the road we're just like
cars but then when it comes to stop
signs they in lights they just [ __ ]
close don't they
so you're not like you know it does
embarrass me to though injuring by
Sunday morning when you see those groups
of bikers yeah who decide they're gonna
relive the glory days
well you not about real biker gangs yeah
not real back with the boys the older I
get older guys now I have the bandana
and Harley and they have like American
flag and just a group of them and
they're just gonna ride yeah and they
pass the music yeah yeah yeah they take
off as like guys just say you know we're
[ __ ] we're still keeping it real be
one of those one of them is it an
accountant yeah if you're an outlaw GM
and I like a warehouse sometimes you
don't know sometimes you get those kind
of the old [ __ ] boy groups right dad
[ __ ] boys but then there's some real
ones too don't [ __ ] about that guys look
at these morons and then you see like
mom gold on the back of my house angels
there's another group to call Loki I
just suffer no way out of there the
there's a camera where that there
they're like god I saw them in Vegas I
was like okay there's some bad boys yeah
and they look at me and they're like
vodka the Vagos gathers oh yeah we're
gonna Venice all the time there yeah I
don't want any trouble I don't think you
should be in a gang when you're in the
age right like 30 I think gang is done
yeah if you're a [ __ ] and you're over 40
yeah you know what time to grow up yeah
it's done grow up it's done sellers know
we're all colors what what all the
colors oh good come on like this thing
look at that motley assortment though at
least they live it
yeah you live it just it you know I'm
with Joe a little embarrassing not that
age if they look at that guy arrested
with the hands in the tattoos behind its
back yeah too old bro you're too old for
that I probably got kids yeah
what are you doing wear a sleeveless
leather vest yeah stop I don't know got
a stop man part of it is just that
they've had they've lived and a life of
crime for so long I know but one day
they wake up at 50 in the yo oh yeah
toss on a leather vest leather vet where
hey honey where's my oversized Dickey
shorts should be seen that at the age of
40 hey honey where's my bandana and
sleeveless vest I mean where's my
quarter white house slippers in hi sock
I was on record oh my go on record say
I'm not make a funny bugger approve of
this is such a pole you are a [ __ ]
though apologize to my no I'm just
saying can you imagine being 50 and
doing that so what do you do you
probably have a choice you're in it
honey grease up the hide what are you in
no you definitely have a choice it you
have a lot of years went by where I went
I'm gonna go this way
well you're you gotta be down for the
cause well you know what's crazy about
those biker guys they lost track of time
[Laughter]
no I don't know I don't know what you're
talking I would just say those guys lost
track you they lost though that they
lost track of time
right there no biker gang started
especially after Vietnam yeah that's it
well guess what man let's do a nineteen
yeah man what are you doing yeah okay
guys keep talking no I like Hells Angels
dude well the Hells Angels came to my
show and they're like dude you want to
come I think the biggest guy I've ever
you know I've been around out this Hells
Angel was so big and scary and all of
them went up for the meet-and-greet I'm
like oh well this isn't good the nicest
guys grin and they're all drunkenly guy
goes
we own the strip club up the up the
block you want to come I swear to god he
goes all the birds are sucking off the
boys the birds the birds are sucking off
the boys I went all right man it was
just wrap the street just Google you'll
find it man come up there ask for me on
it no doubt I will see you there what's
his name do you remember no no I'm
talking this [ __ ] is in
Minnesota no joke big and all the boys
were there oh yeah you know birds these
workers fool these ports all they could
have say this right now big boy those
guys you don't just get into the Hells
Angels without being a certain kind of
badass and also girls like those guys
they had eyes like those those guys like
those guys do I robbed him date for sure
oh yeah I was like oh my god these some
gnarly oh yeah yeah they're out like
we're a different breed yeah I'm not
into this
yeah and ladies the ladies I'd be on the
flat was so big I'd be on the back yeah
Brendan Brenda's got an employer now
like Bruno rizzz by birds you mean boys
this birds hungry too hey don't forget
about the boy birds in San Francisco oh
no you were in Minnesota Minnesota dude
yeah was a gnarly [ __ ] patch there
dude yeah that's badass
I'm not [ __ ] I'm not [ __ ] with me
there's no hell no I'm scared of them
are terrified of them Joko made fun of
their best hey but did you uh you know I
made fun of them I don't know if I
jumped on it - I jumped on it - call me
a bird I'll be a bird I'll be good for a
couple of Hells Angels dad every time a
bird I'm a bird King attractive bro
nobody wants all your worms out and
daddies know what he wants oh nothing
oh man one Hells Angel at a time
nobody's interested you at a time
daddy's hungry is it a buff a bird
[ __ ] smothered and covered treat my
face like Waffle House Joe I don't think
around my circle let's go man get your
motors run in just your motors I just
smack each one on the ass my face is
covered like a [ __ ] Chernobyl Oh be a
sexier bird tried a different tried
different chirp you to just say tweet
tweet crazy
open up there yeah mama brought tweeting
like crazy right huh I'm so full when he
was going quk I couldn't get any but
when he started tweet tweet yeah he's
been tweeting hey did I tell you that
when Shane Carwin and I were gonna do an
appearance at Colorado Springs and the
sheriff from the police department goes
oh well there's a bounty there's a
there's a biker rally here with Hells
Angels and although the dudes and they
go there's a we got word that there's a
bounty that one of the like the muscle
for the Hells Angel anyone who can find
Shane Carwin fistfight and beat them up
gets like a shitload of money
so you boys shouldn't come in you should
cancer your parents what yeah he was cuz
they know UFC fighters come into town
and they they they step up to the
challenge
enjoy that challenge against Shane
Carwin oh yeah Shankar would get my
beating but what's cool is at home I bet
you those I bet you though I bet you I
bet you that guy would be like let's go
and if he lost he lost oh I don't think
so Brian because they're Hells Angels
yeah so Brian would price our weapon I'm
sorry
Shankar price start whoopin the ass on
it dude check this out shank in the back
now all right Oh Oh fair fight are you I
come at the ads that smuggle billions of
dollars of drugs into this country yeah
here
by murder people I'm talking about my
bat look at how big Shane is look at how
he's right there with with Brock Lesnar
and look at Rogan look at Hogan's face
Haim I swear didn't thought he was gonna
win that fight man I thought he was
gonna win it you were his corner for
that right uh well I walked out with him
but I was at one of his corner man was
that exciting the why well because I
fought Brock Lesnar's so the way they
paired it Shane Lesnar fought then
Shane's basically training partner and
best friend fought Brock Lesnar's
trained partner best friend Chris Tucker
sure so it was my second fight in the
UFC and this Chris Tucker character had
30 he was like 30 and 1 he's bring that
up let me see the face I would Brennan
and touch his last name I knocked him
out you're such a beast brother I was
watching some [ __ ] are you yeah it's
crazy to hear your stories
Chris his name was Chris Tosh that Shane
is such as might come up yeah there it
is the far left one damn dude you were a
beat you look like it's not gonna win
any bodybuilding contest could use a
tough dude
yeah thirty fights [ __ ] what was your
what would you go to punch man you're
right overhead yeah overhand right
that's a good look at that [ __ ] mm-hmm
and then that's me dust off my shoulder
second row fourth picture in that's
after I knocked him off I dusted off my
shoulder like an ass oh that's a little
bit
we had [ __ ] on your shoulder though I
did have bird [ __ ] on my shoe cocky kid
copy your cocky kid confident big
difference you knock this guy out and
soon after you're blowing a Hells Angel
yeah I'm suckin Helford and I got a I
got a shirt that says prospect on the
back big kid is it hard to look at those
pictures a little bit yeah really yeah
don't like rims I've never really go
running this is on old times yeah at all
I'm trying to sell out Brea I'm trying
to come up with new you know yeah yeah
you ain't got time for that I don't care
yeah I actually shut down when people
talk to me about it like there's nothing
worse I don't mind this is that there
was a commie store if I'm talking
someone's
dude and brings up a fight like dude
yeah yeah yeah there's no wrong
environment
yeah please no that's crazy man I mean I
covered some fighting but not nowhere
near there was a high stress time for
you all the time right like all the time
you know in a super straight I knew him
when he was fighting and and like the
emotional stress the constant looming
idea that you're gonna have to fight
somebody yeah that's got a sec I here's
one question this is it always using a
free pass okay this is the one question
that always that I've always wanted to
ask how angry do you get when your
opponent doesn't make weight laughs
heavy weights oh there's never a no
there's no issue yeah I mean you can't
be over 265 yeah I think I fought
let's see you Roy had to make 65 touch
sure after makes if I thought a guy
named Lavar Johnson who's in prison now
I think for trying to kill his wife
but he could have but one Olympia and he
was so Jack on steroids you even said
yet the McCain I didn't hear like you
know we start I think you get during the
way off where when off when I go and
they we go to shake hands I like it Dana
and I think it was Joe silver that I go
well we all know he's on steroids yeah
and then he failed the steroid test
after I beat him that's him there oh you
want to talk about biker gangs oh yeah
that was the muscle
I forget which biker gang him him so
check this out everybody saw he was on
like a six fight win streak knockout not
that everybody so he just knocked out
Pat Barry then they give him to me right
but so wearing a lot of wearing the like
the hotel lobby after the fight I'm
there with my family for some medical
pack see me fight so my whole family's
there and this is after I beat him and
he walked was it happy he kept saying I
didn't fight him cuz I kept grappling
kept taking him down
they had talked about like 14 times some
[ __ ] like that and on the ground he'd go
won't we get up and give people a show
won't we [ __ ] won't we banging bro
and I'm like once you learn jujitsu I
just can't [ __ ] wrestle him so he was
pissed after the fight he's like he
didn't want to [ __ ] fight him like
right whatever I won get my check
we're back at the hotel and all the like
some of the fighters there bomb there
with my whole family like family family
mom brother yeah [ __ ] my uncle who I
love my dad's there everyone's there he
walks him with all the biker gang I hit
my brother hey get ready to go
what are you wanting to get ready to go
there like this that's a gnarly dude and
his biker buddies come up to me and
they're roasting him they come after you
go dude you can [ __ ] fight shook my
hand bought me a drink oh that's good
yeah and then I sucked them off yeah
that's why your brother just my brother
any of those guys has to motorcycle
always respect you cuz you're in the
rear in the cage you've got yourself
there and you're in it I mean how do you
how do you disparage a dude yeah but
that was their boy and I didn't like I
didn't I didn't because he was such a
powerful hit not so much guy on the
ground
it sounds like I'm just gonna take him
down it was like I was afraid they're
like dude you're a [ __ ] like in my face
and I'm there with my fan yeah you only
got one person that's kinda got your
back your brother my back oh yeah yeah
my brother stuff threw me was he
sentenced to it says I think live for
what no I don't think life just here's
the other thing terrible person with his
wife to me my engagement with an amazing
dude yeah really nice really I mean did
all the steroids when I fought him yeah
that's not cool you know it's still was
friends so you got a hefty sentence
really poorly punch and slammed his
girlfriend great bodily injury keep
scrolling down does it say how long you
got and you're 10 years oh [ __ ] plead
not guilty with charge but then switch
this set stance when a full sentence of
over 10 years upon table he has the
judge for mercy so he's given five
because they were I'm sorry is it like
anything else sounds like he's a
complicated guy right really nice to you
but has a dark side that he loses
control
what do you mean anybody else no I don't
understand that what what do you mean
like anybody else no I mean I'm saying
he can be when you're hanging out with
him I'm sure he's a really nice guy a
sociopath
well or or or or just a [ __ ]
sometimes nice all the times dark side
loses control [ __ ] you up well I don't
know people like that there are people
like that III don't engage with any I
have no friends like that there are
people like that yeah that guy yeah yeah
but name general no Mercy's five-year
sentence for the brutal assault
girlfriend did you know he was singing
five
five years you know much Greg Hardy got
you know these other guys that beat the
[ __ ] we got Oh Greg Hardy got zero sir
because that because he scared the
defendant away so they didn't get in
case yeah I think he tried to do that
too right
I don't know Jesus what the [ __ ]
five years for being out you know bad
you have to be able woman we get five
years ahead well also would you come out
and that's your charge hard to get a job
oh oh you oh no you think he's gonna
work in the real world no he's a biker
gang B yeah he's not gonna apply it
subway I see I see a real bike about
like [ __ ] I yeah Sunday Funday bike
no I'm not real [ __ ] man and real [ __ ]
oh yeah gotcha
I got you yeah like Mongol hélène's with
that that's him yeah legit tough dude
man yeah yeah I just more athletic I'm
not tough on them wait there's some
trouble in today for a separate domestic
abuse incident serving 30 days in jail
and having alcohol counseling he was
among five people shot in Bakersfield in
2009 during a family gathering which
left one member of his party dead [ __ ]
it so he was in critical condition had
to have his appendix removed he was able
to recover and resumed his fighting
career Wow was a huge scar on his
stomach that really really long one he
came out the gate super hot and you have
seen like knocked out Pat Barry I think
Cheick Kongo like it's amazing amazing
fights and maybe Stefan Struve and then
he started once people figured him out
then he went on I forget you could bring
up his record chin yeah we got a scar he
definitely [ __ ] those girls on the
back yeah he definitely had a hold him
down choke him to [ __ ] their face uh
where we had here oh so yeah there you
go so yeah he went on a rough skid there
so I got him after he lost his Stefan
Struve
but I didn't come off that so he came in
the UFC yeah so he knocked out two guys
knocked out Joey Beltran beat Pat Barry
and then lost a true via armbar and
that's when I figure out he couldn't
wrestle and then they gave me him and
then he went on but they got rough for
him after that guys like oh we got it
but he's a tough dude yeah
a lot of fights yeah he thought about
fighting though yeah it's just kidding
Oh who's the last fight you're in oh god
if there's one thing I hate worse than
my fighting it's his fire yeah he's in
the ring in the ring just like getting
like a fight I mix it up in the ring bro
do you mix it real straight 911 when did
you have you been in a fight
Chicago is the last fighter how long ago
is that about 10 years ago yeah well do
you know why cuz we're two grown yeah
what happened what happened I forget me
it's just stupid drunk Steve Byrne got
how did you take him my son 16 so he was
six at the time yeah I was fixed now
that's what I knew it was dumb yeah now
they have kids like I literally do I
told you about this like a month ago I
had a meeting at CBS ons leaving this
guy cut out in front of me i honk my
horn he slams on brakes parks it and
gets out and this guy looked like [ __ ]
yeah I'm talking every bit of I felt
like boxcar Willie like a little odd
cute I mean just look like [ __ ] yeah
like when they were giving out to Ashley
when they were given out genetics I mmm
mmm backline boy way back way farther go
back we'll wait gets out the car comes
all red excuse me
five seven five seven Brian
completely out of shape obviously having
a rough day wants to fight hits my
[ __ ] hood of my bug all right and I'm
coming out of a meeting with CBS and I'm
like there's no way this is happening
and and I just go dude you pull out in
front of me I'm just giving you a
warning like you're gonna hit me my
car's gonna just run over yours you know
[ __ ] you gather karmic oh my god is this
really happening I got out of the car I
know it's so weird I go what happened
I'm gonna do what are you gonna do dude
do you have a gun if you don't have a
gun what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do and I can see looks at me see
and I went yeah I know get back in the
car it was so ugly I don't know so
there's no upside there's so I'm so
embarrassed I was so embarrassed because
there's out front of restaurant there
people there just watching people had
their phones out and I'm like well I my
dad yeah and I shot me with CBS
you know one sided you there's no upside
in any way if you win it's worse in some
ways ever seen anyone that gets out of
the car challenge is a fight
- what's ever in that car you need it
dad you don't even know what's in that
car you know know what that's like hey
look that's like me going up to a door
and going open up that door might be an
allergy allergy might be an alligator it
might be a lion who knows you know take
your chances work the flight but my
thing is is you blodnik I can't get out
he goes Gallic I'm like what the [ __ ] is
happenin dude I was mad at myself I got
of the car I got out just like dude what
to tot like what are you doing so check
this out my friend my buddy my buddies
hanging out with a guy you know
and they're at a bar and this guy is a
badass and kind of a bad guy and
firefighter yeah and but also just also
like a guy who plays a little bit for
keeps a little bit off so my buddy who's
a great guy they these two dudes they
for whatever reasons are having worse
the two guys go let's go outside and the
guy who my friends with goes you want
you want to both do this or what and
they go whatever you want to do okay
I'll be outside and so my friend said
when he went out to see what his feels
like I guess my friends gonna fight
these he didn't know him very well but
he goes he's actually taking martial
arts class from him and he goes he comes
outside and these two dudes are kind of
tough come on he's like [ __ ] I don't
know he was really nervous and you know
what the dude was doing he had this long
hooked blade what dude the book the
fighter the guy whose fighter he had a
long hooked blade it was a long and
serrated hook play and you know what he
was doing he was picking his nails with
he wasn't looking at them he's in the
parking lot just going like that and
getting the dirt from under his nails
that's great he didn't do anything he
was just going like that and the [ __ ]
two dudes went they saw him they went
he's got a knife [ __ ] that he's got a
knife and they went right back inside
the bar yeah that's all yeah he was all
you had to do I'm just gonna pick my
nails
yes knife he would have obviously from a
movie I mean this is a guy who's gonna
play for keeps this is a guy who plays
for [ __ ] kiyah dub David awful tell
you the story dub Davidoff took a class
from him ah a knife class no and I know
that yeah wow yeah
not a UFC fighter ya know
this is a different thing this is a guy
so this would be an older guys watch a
ton of fun no this guy's uh he's not
older he was athletic and big and new
had a box and all that but it's just a
different good no professional
background um I think he did he fought
muy Thai in Thailand professionally in
fact is it different I know no you don't
know him you know the guy who you know
the guy whose rhythm Oh gotcha
yeah I just want to say his name because
he's a little scary I met him a couple
times and he's a little scary he was a
little bike but of course he's scary boy
the proof of course because he'll he
will quote-unquote unzip yeah
that's what he called that's what he
called yeah he goes why can I give you a
zipper do you know what he said to me
what he goes like this he goes he'll
former Hells Angel
no he goes like this he goes he I was
standing there and he he said I'll never
forget this he goes well you don't need
a blade more than you know I can take a
3la and he goes and I could scribe your
spine from the front scribe your spine
what's the screening I could take my
knife here and open you up his jet
sounds kind of like a tool yeah he but
he's kind of real to like he's one of
those guys where like you're you're
you're but if so and dude I'm gonna
scrub out no no he just was explaining
what a knife can do he's explaining what
a knife got dinner but why do you
subscribe scry why is he telling other
dudes what the knife can do it like all
right dude okay so because my buddy was
writing a book on AI fighting on
survival and one of the things was was
what's the best weapon I have one of the
things would be a knife in a situation
yeah and then he looked into guys who
actually were knife fighters who taught
Special Forces guys all that stuff so
he's one of those guys who's the whole
life is he knows guns he knows knives
you know he teaches tactical you know
defensive I don't think he's ex-military
just a difference grub yeah has he ever
scribed somebody though probably not
he's probably googled it has he really
scribed anybody has that has anyone been
on the ground he's like you [ __ ]
scribed me man so so so here's how that
your spine right there but but but
here's that just
Oh George you scratch I did I scribe you
good but you know what I felt I felt
from him more that no I felt like he was
he might be a like he like I felt like
there was a lie a fetish to the violence
into it I feel like if you climb even
though you describe yeah like I felt if
you do have a bunch of bodies in your
basement I wouldn't be surprised
that's kind of why I'm that's why I'm
talking about where he's full of [ __ ]
you know I'm saying yeah good cuz most
of the bad guys don't they're not you
know then I get a tip their hat he was
kind of like that I don't clean it up
yeah but if he but if he's telling you
guys about it was a real sociopath so I
got with him who was talking about it so
he wasn't he wasn't that kind of guy he
we subscribed he wasn't he was a rough
character he was rough
he looked like right I believe he I
believe that might be playing a dude
playing another dude but I believe in
that situation he would have used that
knife in it when he was pigtails I
believe that that's what he would have
done he was really news that night were
you there when that happened no no see
yeah this is out oh he's real dark out
and guys like this no this nothing go
what what is it what is the hair I'm on
is just like this Nara I believe I
believe my friend who was there I
believe a hundred percent you know is
when you're fighting it's tough they're
kinda yeah not not when you got a big
long played you tend to see that when
somebody's gone like that you tend to
see it and in a lit parking lot home no
I don't believe I don't I don't either I
just I don't think you really met this
guy you are this guy named Brian
okay I am it was me I Spock man how'd
you read into that your children Joker
how did you read into the fact that I
[ __ ] robbed two spots
haha oh no I under the dipper you're the
zipper I'm the unzip Ronnie count is the
zipper solder man I was trapped to rip
it down zipped it's a little too
Hollywood for me with the pic in and he
goes I'll be your huckleberry
yeah well that's a famous one here
call that the famous line from tombstone
dimer I said I mean he said that and I
and I slew them I slew I slew two men
slew two man I slew them and I went time
to get your spine scribe so as I
scrubbed as I scrap I go scry as you're
going across
uh-huh dude I'll tell you this is gonna
bring this podcast screeching halt but I
just gonna say it there you ever get
PTSD which you've been like I'm gay I'm
like I'm so real those Hells Angels I
was the bird there's no birds boner
busting out of my town all my holes
filled multiple times uh yeah hey guys I
can't pay for dinner but I do have holes
what they call airtight hey guys Genoa
air getting in this guy we don't have
money to pay you guys and we know you
owe it we looked for a gambling debt but
Jo koy chicoy has he's there he's what's
called airtight he's tight guys he's
down to go airtight he's gone for the
air test got two holes he's got to hope
I have two holes in a couple ears
fill me up there you go hands and feet
yeah let's go ah same is Lupino donut
you ever get PTSD from pictures you see
yeah like a dude there's this picture of
a dad and his daughter Castellano I
don't what happened dad and a daughter
trying to cross the border and they're
in the water they but they've showed up
both face down but on Twitter it goes
graphic content and usually it's like a
bird eating a [ __ ] worm oh my god I
don't give a [ __ ]
click on it well that's too graphic
France yeah that ruined my morning yeah
man that got me yeah got me that's I got
me it's all I've been thinking about
this entire podcast even though you made
up an entire story about a guide knife
fighting yeah and we're talking about a
special like thing about that dude and
then you don't see what that's what
happens is you can't watch reflect me up
you can't watch that stuff mm-hmm you
know you could like to click it you was
like I don't know it's in my newsfeed
then I was like too graphic for me again
usually it's like an eagle ripping a
[ __ ] penguins head off well have fun
I had a little PTSD because I I happened
upon a [ __ ] video of one of those
meat grinders did you do it and they put
a dead horse in there a whole horse like
face-first
just through the hole
and everything and the thing goes the
whole yeah like a big horse I doubt that
like roll its ankle on the world I kill
him
it was a live horse I mean it was a dead
horse dead horse but it was a it was a
full-grown horse and this machine that
breaks down meat and I was just like I I
was like Oh things can be so terrible
yeah oh my god yeah you went searching
for that sir no it was it was Phenom
shown to me that ain't on the feed
though bro no I was shown to me by a
certain guy that we the guy who came out
with a knife you want to see a horse he
said you want to see how a horse gets
crushed crap let's do some current
events and I could scribe your spine
this guy you're a liar this should be
called the fighter in the lie we
actually went at the shot called when
the pocket I want to show you who it is
and I'm gonna show you you're lucky we
all have a fact check no I have a fact
check I can show you who he is
you'll see you'll see after I'm done you
tell about the scriber
yeah funny story afraid I'm a little bit
afraid I'm sorry I'm not saying that's
how I feel when you see it I think
you'll go oh okay I don't think so and
it's in your phone huh yeah but you have
his number in your phone or we got to
look at Ted something go have you
scribing oh by the way taste anybody my
nuts my nuts you you know what goes on
down your mind yet Harry things might
try trim them and there's blood
you can snag i snag up i snag up on this
here's a very important question very
important question it's so soft it's the
worst but you you trim your face
sometimes your neck now I know you're
not probably going in to the door for
the ball trimmer what you do is you go
don't be a [ __ ] dude I'm just gonna sir
no I use a little something called
manscape do for the number one men's
below the belt
get it below the belts grooming
landscape offers precision-engineered
tools for your knife you won't need to
be real no Nick or snagging or that that
tender nut case oh yeah that in that
case cuz you know why they got skin safe
technology yeah trial so guess what
don't use the same trimmer that use
your face on you're not disgusting it's
not fun so guess what get into it right
now get 20% off and free shipping with
the code fighter at manscaped comm I'm
not the crop that our man scaped ma NS
see a PE decom promo code two fighter
and they got a crop preserver the anti
chafing ball deodorant and moisturizer
that put you hundred under your arms why
not on your bow yeah I always use the
right tools for the job your balls well
thank ya get 20% off free shipping riff
and also a free travel bag with the code
fighter at manscaped comm that's 20% off
with free shipping and a free travel bag
to get your nut gear into at manscape
comm use code fighter you know but you
can't just sleep on a mattress sets for
everybody
what do you mean well I'm saying helix
sleep yeah they got a quiz you take that
in just 2 minutes complete that and it
shows you the exact mattress you need
for your body the fiber fake the
mattress so your time I'm a heavily
muscled muscled man there's there's
sleep on your side yeah maybe you get
hot yeah maybe a plush firm bed whatever
you need helix got you covered just go
to helix sleep dot-com slash fighter
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
the match you to customize the mattress
that will give you the best night of
sleep ever by its individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
how about that yeah how about they have
a button your war in your row yeah
yes try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but guess what
you can you will oh but you Felix is
offering you guys up to 125 dollars off
all mattresses orders for the farm kid
Lister's at helix sleep comm slash
fighter that's helix HDL is sleep comm
slash fighter for up to $125 off your
mattress ordered now helix sleep so San
Francisco is set to ban all ISA Guerette
by 2020 that are approved by the FDA and
currently no e cigarettes are approved
by the FDA ping yes a it's [ __ ] over
the the young culture everybody
something like six seven high schoolers
some crazy number
wait cuz it smells like candy right oh
they think it's harmless but it's
actually like smoking a full pack of
cigarettes no [ __ ] are they finding
these cigarettes are very bad it's way
worse is it really yeah but but it's is
it it there's no filter but so it's pure
like like a nicotine but isn't a katene
less harmful than the actual smoke nope
yeah because they say smoking a certain
amount of e-cigarettes is the same as
smoking a pack a day when these kids are
doing like a a thing oh yeah it's really
bad for you oh but it smells like cotton
candy and whatever yeah that's like oh
it's cool it's fine yeah you've seen all
the hot ends grandmas with a titties out
in their [ __ ] cheeks out the back
everybody goes apes so many people fave
a lot of weed vaping right I gotta be
honest I don't know anyone that babes
yeah I see it all the time we're at this
door that whole [ __ ] kids there you
know we do with Tripoli is all weed back
there right not the comics though and
it's like though the weird dudes in the
back and every time out they always have
doughnuts back there they have the food
I'm like is there weed in these sandwich
he's got here because you got to ask
those plants were good you and I had a
doughnut sir I ate once yesterday I had
at one chicken sandwich I didn't eat
lost Arbour when I got there boy
how many do you have you had a couple I
saw you I caught you I - huh a two small
sprinkled doughnuts did yeah we're done
for now in half today though so watch
your [ __ ] mouth alright [ __ ] cute
you should take your scribe guy um yeah
but yeah II cigarettes supposed to be
really bad for you mm-hmm you look like
us
though you look like you do Easter girls
got no I don't do anything you do hookah
no have you ever done any drugs
uh yeah very little amounts when I
turned 18 just because I want to try
what kind of drugs you're talking to
heroin yeah black tar no a little bit
dabbled in our what did you do
just uh pot who guys stuff like that
really really mild stuff cocaine huh no
I wish you broke for that I feel like
you ain't cocaine you ain't never try to
blow right what you ain't never been me
blow now looks like she do some cocaine
and write an entire book in yeah yeah I
mean if I could afford it maybe I mean
you know you could I worked okay yeah I
can I'll tell you can my friend air
you know I know getting some rain coke I
know a guy who who was like here you go
and he's got a bat I'm like yeah I think
you can get in a lot of trouble for that
much below in LA I didn't realize how
many people are on drugs I get - oh my
god is always gonna be the guy that
knows a guy yeah I would know but the
best is always if you could go back over
the six years we were doing showing us I
got a good friend is I can't say his
name he's in he's a defense attorney
it's always that yeah that's a cool
though you know that many people cyst
the way our friend right now is using
that guy know that defense attorney I
mean no I don't have no idea anything
but no I do I'm not trying to get out
why don't I want to do that thank you
been secretive this whole time the one
time you need to be secretive you're
lewd to it so the FBI is watching you
dude oh yeah you're not a big drug guy
are you Joe yes he is oh nice [ __ ]
drug I don't do drugs drugs all the time
oh you what about when you dude your
eyes are shifting back yeah you mean
lick my lip your lips are getting yeah
I'm hungry for some cocaine no Joe don't
do it again dick that's all I don't
really like doing drugs I like doing the
things you have to do to get drunk okay
I got it I didn't want that you know
what the cocaine but I suck your dick
god excuse and then you just keep the
cook head okay I like doing the dirty
and you don't really okay likes blood
they don't feel gay yeah yeah I'm
straight enough to like blow and
therefore I do yeah man but have you
ever done any of that stuff or no yeah I
think I did in the past
I don't not your thing no my mother's my
brother is crazy and I saw a lot of
drugs it doesn't work out for anybody
that you know when you're over 30 doing
drought yeah I don't understand that it
just doesn't
nobody did a lot of cocaine nobody had
problems or was broke and did a lot of
cocaine then it got better it never
happened in the history of the world
yeah nobody did a lot of cocaine and
started a business even though you want
to start a business when you're doing
nobody did anything I mean that I had a
friend that had a couple sushi
restaurants both of them gone cuz of
cocaine yeah bad that bad I remember him
closing the windows to his restaurant
trying to hurry up he get everybody
so you just do blow a party going yeah I
said this one really your life man and I
sounds a little done stop talking to him
yeah you got a kind of suction I could
okay or you can't just just always a
party can't be around as a party what
else you got cat oh yeah
so the DMV is set to close for half a
day on July 24th for customer service
training
hopefully customer service training on
moving [ __ ] faster exactly that's
what it is
oh really yeah there's a transition now
with driver's licenses here in
California where they're switching to
the Real ID and everyone is trying to
get in to get the switch but there's
just such a large blocks of people
coming in how's it not automated at this
point like when I was there I'm like how
is it not just why am i dealing with all
these people out like how do I gonna
just do this picture thank you out the
[ __ ] door how's it not automate I
don't understand how DMV still has
printers that make that sound it's so
strange what the [ __ ] it's not 1970
anymore why not put some resource into
it it's so great it's just like I didn't
go there like a month ago it was insane
yeah I was insane oh my god the [ __ ] is
there not a machine I just type my
shitty wait so so you're saying
government isn't efficient so how
interesting it's what drives me crazy
when I hear people like socialist like
like we should meeting more government
more social okay enjoy that [ __ ] how's
it go is the DMV how the [ __ ] is that
with no accountability you're gonna
create more in government agencies enjoy
that [ __ ] [ __ ] off that's the truth
though you're alright what how to pursue
it I get it last night when we were
doing shows at the Comedy Store
Sam Tripoli and Eddie Brava cornered me
we started talking it's conspiracy
theories I got some points man they got
some point I was slowly converting a
little bit you kidding I was all the way
over here like wasn't there Jim Morrison
conspiracy time at Laurel Canyon
conspiracy theories yeah now I'm reading
a book on that a lot of that's God make
coincidences bro uh-huh it wasn't just a
pocket of creativity know where people
were moving there because everybody else
was moving well no because all of them
have military ties all the parents do
all
and other songs her no military right
song say help them help them what well
they're all they're all the families are
there in the same area and they had
their own they had their own production
hmm and and and they didn't get popular
because they were genius songwriters no
nope that most of them even write their
own songs
who did the government know I don't
think the government wrote know they
didn't I can tell you that because
nobody in that governments that creative
no you better shut up right now and tell
me that no there's there's some there's
some weird stuff there well somewhere
it's done what would be weird now
they're also of the Laurel Canyon the
hippie movement work in 1968 yeah Crosby
Stills Nash and young Neil Young all of
them but what happens is when there's a
group of people Hendrix lived there for
a little while Jim Morrison Jews tapas
yep
so Mamas and Papas Jim Morrison both
that serves a military Navy right okay
yeah yeah just saying it's weird they
went to everybody back wall surprised
there was that raft when I'm reading I'm
like yeah but the back then was a heavy
military Thursday that's why I'm saying
it so a lot of them would be military
yeah it's a little wit and it's fun to
talk about it's funny I'm not I'm not
sold on this I you know but what I'm
saying there is a little it's kind of
strange how all those bands back then
came from the same place all parents
were in the same military I didn't know
that oh yeah the hippie culture was
developed what's the idea behind the
conspiracy
well isn't that when it wasn't the
government introducing that psychedelic
drugs at that time correct that's that
that's they were the ones that created
the movie yeah no you don't destroy
radio and destroyed the hippie movement
right and that so after Haight Ashbury
so there was this Renaissance of amazing
music right and it was psychedelics and
then what destroyed the music and
they've been of great documentary on
this was heroin and cocaine
especially heroin once heroin came in
people like Lou Reed who were so
talented it's so promising the Pogues
and all these people and there's not a
book called the dark surfer in my neck
head and it just [ __ ] it's it's when
the music died it killed the music
because so many young people Janis
Joplin so talented dead at 27 and all
him dead is so revolutionary dead at 27
but Jim Morrison phenomenally all that
was you think all that's a coincidence
the helps out at 27 course and also all
the same air all drugged out and all
came from Stan they're all drug addicts
they all were so so all we held was
Jim all of myself hopping are you
kidding me out 27n wasn't into music and
so was so as a Kurt Cobain and all of
them all of them basically were had been
doing drugs for a long time but back
then remember they were closely a lot of
them were copying their heroes like
Charlie Parker and some of the blues
musicians from from Billie Holiday to
everybody else who were already doing a
lot of heroin
so it was like cool to subscribe to
having it but also the hippy a lot of
people think the hippie movement started
an aspirin it didn't though it started
in Laurel cane way oh yeah you're
blowing my melon right you know it
started to create a few ladies and what
they would do is they're in Laurel can
are you reading 1968 that book no it's a
great poem you know Lorcan play it like
right now but we're in Laurel Canyon in
the canyon like sitting on the road yeah
houses and you know the market the
Laurel Canyon mark yeah that's where the
main guys yeah I know exactly son died
there it's crazy you should read every
book and Charles Manson yeah read 1968
it's a great book man really great book
I got it now I got to go that store it's
so fun I always pass that store all dude
that's why I'll try them down there and
then because it looks like something
that now that you said that it looks
like something from that I got mom owned
stores there and yes it's because I
always drive down there so I love
driving through and knowing that yeah it
was everybody would kind of you were a
musician who's really when Deanie had a
house there that burnt down if you were
a musician Falls and wanted to live
there if you were music Charles Manson
lived down lower canyon there was a
migration of musicians who are young and
hungry and they all went there and some
of them all's in the same house at one
point yep called the cabin uh-huh this
is blowing my mind I love this and then
the CIA and this is this isn't
conspiracy CIA has a huge complex in
Laurel Canyon that had its own producing
studios and everything and a lot of
music came out of there which is what a
lot of their music a lot of their music
came out of that see that's what ties
this I could see the weird but the only
think so now that's gone right you know
who owns it Jared Leto he bought it he
owns the entire complex of Laurel Canyon
at the CIA as a building that it was
clearly CIA and I said no it'll be I'm
not Eddie Bravo I'm not saying he is I'm
just saying
would you look at the history of the CIA
in Laurel Canyon all the bands came out
there all the bands dads connect the
military to government how Jim Wharton
was in the music at all you gotta
remember CIA I mean no but this [ __ ] bro
and here's the other will fall in a
conspiracy on hole and I will stamp me
too but I don't go full into it the only
thing with Jim Morrison that that is
strange with it too is so he started to
explode and people worked on his looks
as he did have like a militant military
so he had super military cut right so he
started to get out the hippie movement
and then he'd they would do live shows
off sunset well he can't really lay
you're not great singer a lot of his
guys giving played the guitar very well
so the live show suck dick so his albums
were great because a lot of it was you
know bells and whistles and I just tell
you that whoever's telling you this no
this is about crazy I'm just telling you
I don't know is Jim Morrison I can show
you a live performance I've watched him
he was unbelievable as a man and so
talented for sure Merson and the doors
were insane hey dobe you're missing the
point so you're getting defensive I'm
not I'm saying when he first started out
all the band's they couldn't sell
tickets the performance was so bad they
were younger and they learned how to do
it but but if you if you look at like
how I mean what else is weird is Jim
Morrison the interviews would say his
pants are dead he didn't want any
association so they had no was so
subversive right so so the FBI and CIA
there was a real fear that there was a
like a communist there communes so there
was a real Red Scare remember this was
during the height of the Cold War so
there was a real concern that our youth
were being corrupted by communist
ideology drugs and all those things so
the CIA and FBI and the establishment
found them very threatening and then it
culminated with [ __ ] our boy Charles
Manson killing all those people and
trying to start a race war and that
created such a paranoia because we real
that people realize this shit's real you
got hippies
psychedelics that's where reefer madness
and all the [ __ ] came along and it was
like we got to put a stop to this but
what's crazy to me with Charles Manson
is he has like use a legit singer like
you yeah he got in with with the you
know he was part here here's all part of
the music sound think he lived with them
with the Beach Boys they actually we're
gonna sign him a deal when he got turned
down by the record company that's when
he went crazy that's when he's a common
start killing people you was a good
looking dude young good-looking [ __ ]
kid small but like five four crazy but
sexy and they had music I wouldn't say
who said to hook him up okay young you
look like [ __ ] good no good-looking guys
agree before the swastika look at this
watch it tell me if he's not enhanced
live for I would never say in what I was
handsome no Keep Calm know that so happy
I'd be him in the middle when he was
doing all the crazy she's not a bad
looking guy not good Brian I'm not good
at all girls like them I wouldn't give
him a deal like him there
come on look at his eyes she's not bad
looking not good not good at all he's
very charming you made girls do a lot of
drugs and he pretend he's Jesus very
crazy man he was Jesus and that's the
one thing I want to say but the guy who
was the leader of the hippie movement
they said him and Charles Manson and
they do the compare since it's crazy
he's the same thing and they all
promoted underage sex and it's not
smells a lot of flat back then a lot of
fun that was well that was a Meyer
Lansky I know I'm not Mara Lansky who's
the great director who had sex with the
thirteen-year-old oh yeah Rosen plans on
the landscape yeah 13 year olds I think
it was in Laurel Canyon wasn't it
correct they were in a hot tub they got
her high had sex with her and she was 13
he found out he was going to jail for a
long time fled the country led the
country there was a lot of [ __ ] they
went on a lot well the hippie movement
they they said they the hippies would so
the doors or whoever would play at these
random clubs off Sunset and that guy
forget his [ __ ] name he's just like
Charles Manson but wouldn't kill people
craziest [ __ ] he'd bring the girls in
and they loved because those girls were
dancing and were dressed like hippies no
one saw before so a bunch of people
would come to the shows to watch the
girls band so that guy was always
constantly [ __ ] non-stop say was just
a lot there was a lot of [ __ ] there
big old bushes too big old seven bushes
you know [ __ ] yeah drugs and bushes bro
bushes drugs and both shrubs bushes
drugs and bushes yeah and Bush that was
a good band by the way drugs and Bush
yeah D and just drugs a bush let's start
a band you guys see oh my god I would
love this my buddy dead serious he was
so crazy Johnny here we go
he was so amazing and he was driving and
he's like 50 at the time and I'm like I
don't know 37 we're driving he goes dead
serious he goes we should start a band
yeesh I go that's a really good idea
Johnny yeah what would you playing is I
would sing and I go what would I do I
guess I don't know you move around move
around play the [ __ ] tambourine I
want to start a band with both of you
did you know is this going to Guitar
Center just go in there not knowing
anything you don't you know you start a
band know you don't like to do equipment
you know I like a marine I like to go to
guitar science students in college I go
in there I grab the guitar and just like
TAS think it's [ __ ] sweet man I just
pretend I know what I'm doing I scrap
different guitars I wish I could do that
you can check I play the piano they come
over and they talk to you ya know what's
got a longer neck yeah
signed up for piano lessons at 14 and I
[ __ ] I turned it down a night that's
my only regret yeah man it's a could've
been a great a little late bro look at
my fingers yeah lost track of time play
time man you know we can play like a
concert pianist as Sean Hayes you know
from Will and Grace whoo [ __ ] like
like concert pianist
I don't know him Jack from Will & Grace
at the redhead guy oh I'm too young
look Sean is the best one of the best
people in the world oh he's a genius
he's the best but he's there I love him
so what's he in such a good actor they
redo Will and Grace yep and he's in it
right now
yeah but he's really in person and
hilarious he's [ __ ] hilarious oh he's
so good are the funniest people in the
world can do that show by the way can do
anything can do anything if that show
still going on yeah they brought it back
it's a reboot right yeah with the same
actors yeah Megan Mullally younger and
younger wants you to be in Willingboro I
I went back five times for will and then
I went back four times for Jack dang
never happened just missed it I mean I
[ __ ] got so ready for that audition
between there like broke my back I I
like I wanted it so badly
I've never it's rare that you want
something that bad that I knew was gonna
be the biggest [ __ ] hit ever I wanted
it so badly Max and David the creators
the greatest greatest guys maybe it was
down to you and him I don't know but I I
kept coming back really yeah do you see
your three new and him then auditions
are a [ __ ] bro I come down but
you know what hate to be shitty about it
oh they made the right choice oh they
hate to be shitty about it I'm your
friend
yeah made right choice but you were just
saying out talented he is that can you
play the piano
no no well he can yep you know what you
know what made right show know what they
didn't have a name that that show
someone that could describe it would
have been good right I mean no matter
what else we got all right cats gonna
take control of Peter for our second
because I got a pee real bad let's take
a break
you guys want a break you know no good
okay so a 29 year old Pennsylvania man
was recently arrested because he was
trying to warn everybody in his area
that aliens are gonna come and take over
the world because humans are bad and he
was warning people by making a makeshift
bomb and leaving it at a hotel he
actually went inside the hotel told the
manager hey I made this cool bomb and
the manager said please bring it outside
call the police and he was arrested yeah
well I like this guy he sounds like he's
not dealing with a full deck he is
certain that the aliens are gonna come
for us okay hey that's called being
certifiable you know crazy
needs help right I don't know man it
looks pretty cool to me it's pretty cool
I mean he's pretty cool to me like I'm
try it's in schizophrenia hits men in
their 20s you know that anyway talking
about aliens do you unsee the [ __ ] in
area 51 dude on Rogen I didn't you have
seen it no what's his name his name
Laser laser Bob laughed at me cuz if
anyone needs to see you need slide dude
[ __ ] why aliens are real bro I was just
walking listening I know that's watching
I know everything on Netflix like I know
I'm usually the anti conspiracy guy but
you know what I've looked into it Hunter
and Eddie's kind of right now I'm not
trying to fist you not for me bro I'm
threatening you right what what is yeah
we're to God what [ __ ] aliens are real
they are the real are you arguing aliens
are real I don't think there's any heavy
dolls you [ __ ] okay take it easy
bhakti stay there so evidence Hey
ah this Bob laser worked on you laughter
you're getting.i calmly sir okay call
this way cool aliens you should be
called okay right laser you butcher
every name but lasers what like so Laser
laser believes no no not believe dude he
was laser out there was brought there
worked on nine different UFOs
we have video he worked on nine
different nine of them at area 51 dude
if you discredit laser i'ma [ __ ] you up
I just feel like wants to you okay I
just feel like I just want to say one
thing is it possible that he is a liar
why would he why would mr. why the [ __ ]
do you believe it guy that cleans his
nails with a [ __ ] knife and scribe
several because I was trying to warn
this guy actually worked with UFOs on a
very secured area 51 guys where's the
evidence
oh yeah was it granny did you not
educate yourself before you do there are
aliens are real aliens are real I would
bet my bottom dollar made contact with
us
they sure have certain on earth yeah
have we have there's one oh yeah we got
space 9 of them nine why don't you go
hey dude bright won't you grab your
phone real quick your iPhone you don't
believe in a you sound like this guy who
put a bomb in the [ __ ] and now do I
sound like an educated human being a
think it easy dude you don't believe in
eight are you have your hat off and why
are you pointing it at me just relax
supreme expensive okay dude you don't
believe in aliens I don't know
aliens but I don't know that we have
nine spaceship I would love that what do
you think whirring here he said he
worked on him what did he do on and they
soup them up I'm asking I'm asking
questions drive me crazy bro I don't
know can I tell you a story real quick
yes he's just real quick please
so Chris D'Elia is on the road going
right he's opening for me yeah we get to
this one town every city that we go to
were the funniest guys there yeah
anywhere we go to a coffee bean we go to
a Panera Bread were the plenty of spot
better people to walk in we get to this
town funny Posse it's it's called I
think it's called Dayton Ohio I think
I'm pretty sure you behind today we got
a date and all of us so we're not the
funny people everywhere we go the Panera
we go to a [ __ ] some restaurant and
everyone's odd everything everything is
a lot so Chris and I go to the room and
we start laughing and we're like dude
you know what this town is the
government built this town because this
is where they breed aliens and then they
breed them here and then they ship them
out into the regular World's Fair after
they work here like they work with them
here to deal with like people that are
transient coming through and dealing
with regular humans right we were
laughing we're dying so hard at this
theory right so the guy that comes and
picks us up for the for the show he's
driving us to the to the to the show and
and then Chris is sitting in the front
seat I'm sitting in the back and I go
hey my man um are there any aliens or
spaceship set that uh fly around here
and we just we giggle to ourselves Chris
and I are laughing to ourselves right
and the guy goes yeah uh roswall crashes
here the the spaceship from Roswell
Roswell right Roswell Roswell the
Roswell spaceship is here and it's in
hangar let's check this out he goes chin
you you and you're on the alien train as
well I've always kind of believed that
yeah listen this kind of believed the
best part of the story he goes the
Roswell crash is here it's in hangar
like 52 you can look at hangar 18 hangar
18 I swear to God Chris and I we were
laughing all day all day we were
laughing when this guy said this Chris
night we look [ __ ] ghost face we look
at each other like what the images Brian
you
don't think it's inbred leadership this
is a real hater in Dayton Ohio that
looks like a hanger now listen let's
lose it no we were joking around about
this whole million [ __ ] we won that guy
said that to us it freaked us the [ __ ]
out because that's literally how that
town felt it felt like they were like
breathing up human I'm just saying it it
will decide there might be a roof oh
alright well that's my story ask Chris
crystal B I'm telling you gotta listen
to this Bob laser Lazar I'm just those
are Lazar now he has a documentarian
that that's so fake the documentarian
that's with him is a bit of a tool where
you Mike I don't believe this yeah but
this Bob laser guy it's real [ __ ] man
yeah hmm yeah why were you so I just
said my dad was mm-hmm
you don't believe in any of it you know
all I said was life form I just said hmm
yeah you guys I'm not saying
extraterrestrial life doesn't exist of
course it has to you'd have to believe
it does because the universe is so huge
but and they're they what labs are on
guys they have so what Lazar was saying
laser laser was saying is you don't even
know his name but keep car well not calm
laser because way cooler yeah so what he
was saying is the technology that so
that his whole project was to figure out
how these things work like the energy
source is so much more powerful than
ours that he was a scientist and yes
rocket scientist why the government
building jets at the age of 13 out of
his house would you say why the
government why did the government
there's now he doesn't know he goes they
do I have no idea why they won't tell he
goes I thought it was because we want to
advance in our technology we should let
everybody know but the government
doesn't think that way some people some
government yes well it's all government
so some people think that the government
doesn't really see because it released
mass hysteria because their technology
is so much more advanced in ours they
could just [ __ ] blow up the world at
any point yeah and also all religion
would be faked then right
100 yeah it's all [ __ ] but I mean I
appreciate that I don't know what the
was your stats on it they'll be what do
you use I stand in my stance is that I
just can't I can't
so so you have to think about this for a
second let's just say the government
which is always changing right people in
power die new people come in so I mean
no I guess the military also generals
retire and you have new people come in
the structure and it have to be some
kind of there have to be some kind of
law or some kind of agreement written
rule among whoever it might be to say
this stays secret you know harder to
keep secrets all of us are like hmm and
in people in government [ __ ] right so
you don't think there's secret
well the secret was in the government
and national security state Calder's
that's what I'm saying is that there are
national security secrets right so for
sure we're doing their stuff halogens we
have no idea let's just take it we have
a UFO let's say we have a UFO yeah and
it's somewhere and one of these hangars
into them explain to me the the how in
the world would anyone especially I say
what how long has it been there do they
say like they don't know the 13 year
1920 okay good even so so we've kept
this a secret for you know 100 years
explain to me how that would be so and
how people came into power wouldn't say
dude this is fascinating how
investigative journalists scientists who
are so curious about CIA people military
people wouldn't somebody go dude there's
a [ __ ] UFO here it'd be the greatest
most incredible thing with it be all of
us all this would be lining up to go see
this thing right what they don't want
that
now who's it onthe who's they who who's
they the government wouldn't want that
when you say the government who in the
government the government is is
multi-layer so but you guys know the
failure so you're pretending that the
government everything's out on 100 years
you're not gonna keep a secret for a
hundred years you don't think the
government rolls that type of
information just goes in at all society
like imagine imagine if they said that
there is a higher life form and that
there's a nobody can keep a secret for
100 years it's not possible I think
about it there's a you don't think
for a hundred years yeah come on when
the government there's a UFO in a hangar
somewhere and somehow we said you get
into a room when you're in the CIA or
the military guy come here this has been
passed on from generation to generation
there is a u.s. below but we must keep
it a secret from the people not all know
what no but only certain branches work
on it so the whole not everyone's even
is into it what branches let's just say
it's the brat let me give you numbers
you know area 51 it's a real complex
crasher okay but I'm saying and that's a
secret yeah but but but that's might be
secret technology to the government
secret technologies right weapons today
you're contradicting yourself that's the
technology but I'm saying that that is
because we keep it secret from Chinese
espionage Russian espionage things like
that as well right yeah robotics and all
that stuff so and and and by the way
that there's a lot of industrial
espionage so a lot of that a lot of that
technology comes out of industry Boeing
Lockheed even Apple and those people
have their own kinds of things right and
so now they have certain areas that are
highly secretive so an apple but comes
out with a new technology the [ __ ]
secrecy is crazy around that right so
everybody has an interest in keeping
that so that the proprietary stuff that
you can make money off of it doesn't get
stolen I'm talking about a UFO that's
been there forever that came from maybe
from that's just me I don't know would
we but you're saying you don't even
Justin because the government hasn't
come out and told you about that
yeah how that's silly what's the
justification you know thirty years
forty years of a UFO why why wouldn't I
be able to see it wouldn't everybody be
curious no how would you keep all those
people how many have no matter how many
okay hold on what do you mean people
let's say 15 people worked on it let's
say 15 people right cuz that laser was
there they retire and then what or some
died from radiation from work whatever
okay four of them have died from
radiation
whatever that yeah cuz it's so power
right okay but so we know that but but
please tell me where in the where in
which my days do but we're in
legislature let tell me where it says
you're not allowed to talk about this
well you somebody in Congress are
wouldn't cuz I mean Congress go uh no no
hold up Navy SEALs can't talk about
their missions I know but this is a UFO
what why is yeah but if you're a part of
that
brand that's what you signed I think is
the justification for keeping the
secretive tell you what though I can
tell you what the citizens you don't
think they have contracts where they
can't just go hey you can't work on it
and then go on a nine news tomorrow in
announcing oh wait why would they do
that with a UFO I don't understand it's
because the wrong know we don't know how
long be your that arguments not you're
saying the secret states been there for
15 years here's the reason why they
don't want the world known we have the
technology whoever graphs that
technology and breaks it down can run
the world if you can somehow manifest
how powerful this is but a minute we
control everything but what about all
the religions out there when they find
out that there's a larger being that's
bigger than there exists a god to make
so the government asset so the US
government cuz we can't release this the
US government whoever that is because
you guys haven't told me yet let's just
say it's a group of people it's not a
cover more you know there's governments
within the government Ryan you really
don't think there's secret societies
within the gun I can't believe you don't
Saul Ange is that that was say all what
I'm saying is that not I think that it's
just one dude and he's the president no
no it's gone oh no no you're hearing me
other branches that you're not hearing
me you're not getting where we are
hearing you know the CIA the Defense
Department there I think there are 19
different intelligence agencies so you
don't believe could I just say one thing
in your argument we go
you don't think there's nothing to the
word secret in secret you're you're
talking about a service you're talking
about something so different right now
what I've seen is if there's seed there
there are branches within the government
that help could Joe you're not telling
you you don't you don't tell me anything
I don't know but what you guys what I'm
saying to you guys is your hasn't gotten
there we're telling me there is an
extraterrestrial technology okay
yeah that the US government's had for I
guess it's how many years old we don't
know we've been here about Roswell since
the 50s
that's what up we've been here okay so
let's just say there's a fifth letter
it's 68 years please guys if you could
tell me how in the [ __ ] you think the US
government whether it's a secret or the
deep state or whoever you want to call
okay how the [ __ ] are you gonna keep
that a secret where would it get out be
because it scary enough because it all
goes down at the end of the day no no
not true if these we don't know we don't
know we need Brandon the Freedom of
Information Act you can you have access
to anything we try to stage a coup in
Iran that's called the freedom of
information have access to everything we
don't have actually you don't have
access to access to state secrets guys I
understand that I understand the big
chance and now that there are seat there
are secrets that the US and all
governments have in their intelligence
service yes
Harper Senate will never get out and one
of the big problems is civilian
oversight which we're supposed to have
and sometimes the CIA takes license and
we don't know about it and then it gets
blown up you're on contra Lots
what about the JFK files like that where
they can't release it because we can't
release some it to the public because we
don't want the backlash from the pub
what about some that senior you see
what's what's so funny to me is guys
always say this they always go well they
can't release it because there'd be mass
hysteria and there'd be a huge backlash
who's they
you mean they sign who's they so somehow
you guys think that if you're in the CIA
or you're in defense intelligence or
your or your whatever you are here soon
they're liable that you guys are
assuming that that that that like
they're open all day there's curious
nobody there's curious and so and
nobody's there's curious and that it's
really easy to keep secrets for 50 60
you're you're wrong about that I not
even think you're wrong if you think no
secrets are being held for the last 100
years yeah you think they're not of
course they are it's all out there yes
it's keeping secrets for 70 years ha you
don't think they have any secrets you
think all the Talon popular you can
productive online consumers can gotta
save you one secret go ahead
laughs this prize would laugh in your
face it was laughs in your face
historians would laugh in your face
don't be not high and it becomes a
matter of record we know everything that
went on in World War II kit we know
everything I went on World War two herbs
then when I was VL I know pretty much
everything we know all right some
secrets we do know everything we know
about the Phoenix approach the
government lets you we know about the
assassination programs one of they
didn't put out every you think they put
out everything like after a while in any
in any government when people die and
were they retire and stuff this
information comes out no of the person
passed and not all the jobs they worked
on the secrets that they've had so these
so you're releasing full so it is your
position I want to hear this I want to
hear you say this out loud it is your
position gentlemen that the government
has secrets that the government has kept
and I'm gonna give you a number because
it this goes back to the 50s oh there is
a that there is a UFO out there or just
some extraterrestrial technology somehow
landed in American hands because it
landed in Nevada let's just say I'll
give that to you now no they're not now
are you saying whatever this are you
gentlemen saying to me that somehow the
CIA the secret see yeah so the CIA
corner has secret for the second oh the
CIA that that [ __ ] that that
organization that's not a bureaucracy at
all it really knows how to keep secrets
know what I'm saying that's insane are
you saying that we have kept this UFO
technology and this year the existence
here a secret from the American people
and the world for 68 years yeah yeah and
it's yeah and it's in a and it's in a
tray a huge building somewhere in area
51 really don't dance because over six
years we've been trying to Brian try
gold area 51 right why why did it take
this is awesome president that the
president will you listen can you shut
the [ __ ] up it's every president before
Clinton always said there
no such thing as area 51 in minutes not
government own every President Bill
Clinton was the first one to ever go
yeah there is and I do recognize their
secret sizes there are secret sites we
have the secret it's a secret but why
don't I just keep it nice I can say
there are no no I didn't say that
documented this is open to the public
I'm not saying the government doesn't
have secrets we have intelligence you
said it all get I'm saying is that
you're not keeping a secret who's not
here's the car you are at there are
secrets everything's here 100 years all
that silly even in Vietnam that's play
even Vietnam we know you have access to
anything you're right you're you are
[ __ ] insane I love how you guys love
it
so who's keeping it is it why government
a government wide over me oh so you
think everybody that's in the Secret
Service just gonna open but behave this
one I did they make this right they
making this jump I'm sorry caustic to
UFOs no no no you guys don't know this
bro you don't like this Renan you don't
listen we're live we're not a listener
quiet everyone quiet both of you
I know more about history than politics
because both of you you're not even your
infants right now be quiet
Wow be quiet not so hot because you're
ignorant listen to me how is it your
honor Lou what I'm saying no secret why
is it is that it's very far-fetched to
imagine guys that the government is able
just able to keep a secret for 68 years
about a UFO that exists that's very
far-fetched to believe that's all I'm
saying guys and why am I saying that
because at the end of the day with with
the US government the way our government
works and let me give you my logic for a
second please the way the US government
works is eventually with the Freedom of
Information Act eventually when the
secrets are considered when when
national security secrets are no longer
considered important to keep it is made
available historians and lots of people
are into
in this stuff okay now hold on hold on
before I say that you if you did have
technology that was a UFO guys that was
68 years old and let's say it's too
extraterrestrial are you following me
it's really important technology there
would be have to be some kind of
governing body that legislated that
would that made it a law right there
would have to be and I still haven't
found that so when you guys talk is real
you know when you get but don't jump
today I know all all about government
you study in college
no no I'm history you're just so if
you're going you're going Brian you know
all about government that's all I'm
saying
well that's why you just told us no no I
didn't I said you said we're infants you
are let me explain a little bit about
how government works
you do need policy that would make this
know I've been lawful look and very
smart people most very smart people kind
of go okay why do you think all this go
you have photos Rogen's not smart are
you smart enrolled in I don't know what
are you talking about why are you
bringing Rogan into this she just said
lotty podcast oh yeah I got his podcast
it's very fun and intriguing to believe
that a UFO exists it is it's [ __ ] fun
I give it to you it's so fun why though
guys is it always hearsay why do I have
a guy who worked there and he's telling
us that he worked on it and all we're
left with correct me if I'm wrong is
cannot to have to believe him can I get
some evidence please so you don't
believe anything less you have evidence
nothing is realities of evidence Brennan
is that fair am I being a dick about
that I just need some evidence what
about the videos they have you're gonna
say they're fake show them to me but you
can bring your much like and again every
video I do every three eruption but
everybody wants it great clear enough
though yeah legit Evan yeah do you
believe chaos do you believe that I
don't know I can't say they're not okay
there you go come on guys like I need
more than that and you do too no not
here you're being very um how do I say
it
what but did you see what I'm saying
dude I just need some evidence Joe I
need evidence
check oh yeah there there's a lot of
evidence out there especially with area
51 is there though right yeah
but there's a lot of there's a lot admit
that look I'm saying is that am i bad am
i wrong for being cynical am i wrong for
being am i ignorant for being cynical
when I when it when and what I mean by
how the government works guys I'm sorry
that I sound like a dick when I say that
I know more I'm just talking about the
way the government works
there are there's legislature you have
to pass and be you they're here I'm
sorry you might know more about the
government Congrats that's great oh
that's great you spent time studying
that that's fantastic
anyone can learn that yeah what I'm
saying to you is it's not crazy to think
that the government keeps secret say
that of course the government has
secrets whether it's aliens whether it's
war whether it's maybe SEAL mitches sure
it's not crazy or some far-fetched world
that they hide evidence from the pub
locator not public I don't think you
have a lot but we don't think a UFO
though would be like say so everywhere
all of us pilots everybody go like this
what the [ __ ] is that right
so think about you'd have to be like we
found our UFO who are you gonna tell who
found it who are you gonna tell and why
keep that a secret why wouldn't you
though like I know what we said no one
received area isn't a very big factor in
that what you beam at a see I don't
think that would be mass hysteria dude
you don't think that tell your whole
world that there is a larger life that
religions not read that yeah that
everyone has believed in this God which
you probably believe in which has no
facts by the way I don't I don't know
but you're just saying that you want
facts we get all these religions are
based off of hearsay as well as the
mythology Anna Anna Anna Anna but
there's no facts there's no facts
there's no facts there's no
documentation about Jesus Christ that's
exactly right so I tend to be a little
bit of an agnostic like I'm like I don't
know but there's no you and when they
say that they did they do have a higher
life form who that is head though right
if the cover of releases that
information just imagine what happens
with every single religion that every
every every group that's out there that
just believes in a specific religion it
would be so hold that we have more legit
evidence let me know aliens then we do
violate on what he's saying cuz that's
what I meant when I say this is not how
government works let me just let me just
say this okay great so now what your
suit is assuming
is that there is a policy in the US
government that would that's there
there's a group of people a governing
body yeah there would have to be that
has say-so on whether or not the
information is true love like the public
should know about something hunter based
on whether or not it creates mass
hysteria so so so that that can you tell
me what that who is that body just tell
me who it is
do you know cuz I don't I I don't know I
know I want to say steady the government
like I don't know if one agents hold on
but even that you're hey B B's ain't
hold on but beep I know you studied
again history you keep telling us
because you don't know it's not real
well because you don't know that brain
nobody else does either can you tell me
who it would be deserted someone they
have liability right for you to sit here
and act like that that the government
lied about area 51 that's a branch of
government that was controlling that
area no if you treat that area Noma if
you dried area 51 it says you will be
shot change kill pacify items that's a
government body right here you know
about it yeah same thing with this but
yet the President of the United States
was saying there was no such thing as
area 51 look can I just say there are
secret areas Jo doesn't mean that there
you have oh right that's not what you
were saying what you were saying who are
these governments so there's one right
there they get it they get a technology
and in the room a bunch of guys go in
the room and once you guys go and by the
way they're military guys would imagine
right no white right well watch they go
we can't tell the American public or the
world is because there'll be mass
hysteria okay the terrace that happens
all time with Terrace attack yes but we
also know about well no we don't you
remember we used to have the we used to
have the threat levels about remember
that those are done right levels those
are gone well because they were just in
effect that people weren't but also I
know guys who were right to quote you I
know guys who are in that business you
go oh my god if we announced on CNN
yes exactly threat level hundred percent
be mass hysteria we cannot do and also
we we don't want to tip off that there
are a lot of reasons for that right
there are a lot of reasons and I agree
100 percent this head guys goes it would
be massive stories the US government
does want to scare the [ __ ] I ready
because there are real threats out there
right a hundred percent what I'm trying
to say is this if they found a UFO hmm
and it's there and we let's be honest
we're talking about it going back to the
50s I don't personally see how in the
hell you go I need evidence here I need
evidence that you don't think they can
keep a secret I don't see why you think
for 68 years no you don't think so you
think so everything's out in the groups
some past significant 68 years I mean
every UFO yeah be everything how about a
marriage the most no secrets I think so
oh come on yeah you're just playing
devil's advocate no I'm not oh great
let's just stick to it no let's let's go
big in UF so you're voting a hanger how
are you gonna keep that a CEO forty a
sixty eight years honestly do you really
think we get people to see yeah yes why
there's a shitload mass hysteria so they
go can't do it and everything you know
that you know it's all civilian
oversight so somebody in the civilian
government Trump would have to know
wouldn't he
every president we've ever had would
have to know and their chief of staff oh
well that's right that was this would
not wouldn't wouldn't win the White
House
overall correct that's just not a
Secretary of State defense secretary of
defense yeah the undersecretary fans all
the people that had are responsible
those people are first of all so that
they're civilians they're appointed they
come in kind of with their own agenda we
know that the White House can never keep
secrets right they're always [ __ ]
backstabbing each other secret but
they're always backstabbing each other
yeah so these people know and every
demonstration every administration has
known this right even though it's top
secret I do really think that that
somehow every president says we can't
release this because it's top secret
like I know it's fun to believe I just
need can I get a little evidence you
think all presidents don't relate do you
think they don't die with secrets you
think you're all everything's an open
but I said of course they don't say just
UFOs oh yeah no I'm saying well secrets
are we have an intelligence community
right and yes and there's top-secret
clearance right and so you you if you
say anything it's treason you go to jail
correct you can even be sentenced to
death correct right so one I'm not
saying that the US government doesn't
have secrets based on a credible threat
China Russia whatever it is right
100% we have an intelligence apparatus a
very big one with a blank check
basically I am still trying to figure
out why in the world UFOs would be kept
secret from us and I don't believe that
answer Joe you wanted to say that we
don't understand what you don't want out
we need a move on where you can keep
going circles and you guys showed you
guys the percentage-wise no remember
we're idiots
yeah percentage-wise percentage-wise way
too guilty percentage-wise you're
telling me what do you think do you
think that that I can't get up on a
hanger and anger what do you think I
don't know but I do I think I know for
sure the government I would bet my life
on it
withheld secrets from us oh I'm not know
about about UFOs about everywhere talked
about you know you can't just say one
thing to you if they all I was talking
about but there's always he he what I
got got me mad was that you guys are
jumping over here and going you're
saying no secrets no guys I'm not saying
that I'm talking about specifically this
guy talking about how he worked on a UFO
I don't believe him listen he's a liar
okay
I'm your friend [ __ ] nails in the
knife well yeah it's not too hard to
believe because I know that guy and I'll
show you after we're done that that's a
little easier to believe isn't it then I
had a pocketknife and his nails crazy to
me but yeah it's crazy
I believed you you know everything about
history and we're small everything about
history big people know history and
although you guys that's exactly what
you guys are out flying you guys are
saying [ __ ] you say
vanna knife right now I described you
know I hate this cries you know this and
your smart guy and I'm not saying this
to diminish you anything I would say
there's smarter people who defend the
alien stuff chef's know the government
better than you I guess yeah well no no
no I'm telling you there are it went
there Ike smart dude you're always
running late
yep you forgot your socks it's not
[ __ ] for your sock yeah did you
forget your sock yeah we're infants but
you forgot that's not fair dude you're
late to work you're being rather than
traffic because you live here it's work
you know what time this start yeah yeah
like you forgot yourself now you guys
are fighting right now as I did yes [ __ ]
I'd say that's about maybe one of the
greatest cause that I know guys are
impotence I went to college it's like
history behind you and telling me that I
was saying I was insane you are a bit
see your true colors in short you're a
Scorpio smart you are
Brian you in dude you can't talk to him
smart little people don't understand me
what happened to him and keep up you
smart you're so so so so smart man
I am we should stop it we're ten which
we can't we shouldn't even be in your
present it's just I just I shouldn't I
need more evidence about UFOs that's all
I do like I don't believe the government
casts secrets or would keep it safe
yep you're right dude they can or whoa I
win and I don't believe that area is you
just I don't mean keep it's evil to see
eight years about a UFO in a hangar in
area 51 or anywhere else I don't have as
possible if you say bro well we're in
and you guys you change my diapers to
rethink your government doesn't work
we're gonna play we can't tell anybody
it'll get rid of religion go read a book
Joe I'm gonna read a book on history on
history I think government I knew I knew
once I did that don't worry
because he majored in history in college
do you know that oh my god and you're
[ __ ] him I'm a [ __ ] infant I'm
sorry I'm sorry you have to do that in
this area the true colors flying out man
no no you were being insulting and you
were your house insulted you were going
you don't believe any secrets you're
like I was like that's not what I said
that's my origin started with that big
and then you went to you oh yeah give it
one day you don't came out swinging you
don't listen will you do if you don't
save and you go and you jump you go I'm
not doing so it's more likely to believe
I'm gonna jump in I'm gonna jump in you
know why he gets defensive
cuz when you talk and you think you
throw a little easy - meaning you're
demeaning and you do this like sorry I
have a brain you don't understand why
you believe in like like aliens but I'm
a human being with a brain it's very
educated brain so I understand so I said
I should have had a better approach oh
yeah I was loving something there's no
one like to get talk like Geoghan I
can't wait
you don't you don't believe in right
here's your watch
I'm in the middle yeah
what I'm saying is then I know this for
a fact I don't know you don't know right
yeah neither one of us knows Joe doesn't
know one knows their so when you're so
diehard set on it I was it's just weird
I just I just I don't have a dog if
there are aliens fantastic there's not
alright yeah you know what it is when a
guy on gets on Rogan and he worked there
and he talks about it I go is there any
government agency is there anybody yeah
no yeah yeah I didn't mean Rogan go
ahead tell them come on I'm sorry he
believes in the same story that we
believe in say it look say - it's
[ __ ] face man
no I can't wait a night spicy baby bro
don't squat against cries please I'm
sorry I just don't believe in UFOs okay
until I steal all on small all of the
small you know everyone's an infant set
your camera right there just men in wake
up naturally and that's when the
historian becomes a [ __ ] let's get out
of here man wait let's go undo it
anymore
no we don't
I have to go now I have to go so does
Jaya [ __ ] you ruin their yeah you did
I'll be at Bray out this Thursday Friday
say that's tomorrow Thursday Friday
Saturday and Brea improv get your
tickets now after I'm in Cincy than in D
get your tickets t pack a calm Hey the
brilliant one where are you gonna be
alright hey infant come see Brian show
he's a really kid less funny guy lets
you in a tent talk kid let small
everyone who know the kid let's need to
know this I'll be in spoken to life
eleven twelve and thirteen turquois
gonna open for me
and then San Francisco cops July ninth
twenty look I know there are a lot of
diehard UFO guy special oh yes the best
special on Netflix right now like the
best for you guys coming in hot check it
out right now
coming in hot calm you want to tweet
about it no don't think hey remember
both of my email Ryan's a dick you're a
dick this is fine kid where I'll be guys
bye